GOOD AFTERNOON AND. WELCOME
EVERYBODY.
WE HAVE AG THAT GOOD TURNOUT
TODAY ONCE AGAIN THIS IS OUR OUR
FIFTH HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY.
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ON THE
SEA AND WERE EXCITED TO BE HERE
AT OUR STATE CAPITOL STAY FOR A
FIFTH HEARING TALKING ABOUT.
THE FINANCING OF THE SEA VIA.
SAY THE BILLION DOLLAR
QUESTIONER EVEN MORE.
YES I KNOW WE WE WE'VE BEEN
AROUND THE STATE'S WE HAD OUR
FIRST OF COURSE THE HEARING HERE
ABOUT A YEAR AGO. AND OUT OF AND
IF YOU OTHER CITIES IN OUR PER
BACK.
OUR NEXT YEAR WILL BE ABOUT
LOOKING AT ACCESS ISSUES BUT
TODAY WE'RE FOCUSED ON ON.
THE FINANCING PIECE OF THAT WE
KNOW THAT'S.
A CRITICAL COMPONENT THOUGH YOU
KNOW THAT MONEY ISN'T
EVERYTHING.
THE SYSTEMS ARE IMPORTANT WHAT
SAM WHAT'S IN THE. IN THE IN THE
IN THE SETTING WHETHER IT'S THAT
A FAMILY PROVIDER AT CENTER AT
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WELL THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS BUT I AM GOING TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE LOOK AT THE
ECONOMICS OF OF HOW WE MAKE THIS
WORK IN CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE AN
AN EXCITING UP PANEL HERE TODAY
I KNOW OUR SPEAKERIS GOING TO
BE HER IN A MOMENT TO. TO JOIN
US AS WELL.
DO HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS
FOR FROM ANYBODY.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE WITH YOU.
I'M I KNOW WE'VE BEEN TAKING A.
OUR COMMISSION IN ON THE ROAD
SHOW IS WHAT I CALL IT AND I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
TO. TO GO TO THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND.
HEAR INPUT FROM EVERYONE THAT'S
INVOLVED AYE AS.
MANY OF YOU KNOW I'M A FORMER
TEACHER AND I KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION I WITH THE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS ALL I'D
NOBODY KNOWS BETTER THAN THE CAN
HARDEN TO JESSE. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
I THINK THAT.
WITH THE PANEL HERE OF FABULOUS
AMAZING PEOPLE I THINK WE CAN.
FURTHER UP THE THE MISSION
INSTEAD OF JUST HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS HOPEFULLY AFTER WE
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
FUNDING I THINK WE CAN COME UP
WITH SOME GOOD PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES AND. YOU KNOW SOME
TANGIBLE OUTCOME SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD AND REALLY.
HAVE OUR COMMUNITIES BE BETTER
BECAUSE OF OUR EFFORTS I THINK
YOU'VE TO THE A PANEL FOR BEING
HERE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO UP A
ROBUST. DISCUSSION AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN CONTINUE AND.
YOU
SOLVE EVERY SINGLE ISSUE.
TOMORROW RIGHT SO THANK YOU.
OKAY.
SO INTERESTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME ALL OF YOU I AM SO GLAD
TO BE PART OF THIS COMMISSION.
SUCH AN IMPORTANT COMMISSION.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
PREPARING. FOR THIS IS THE
PREPARATION IT'S ALL OUR REPORT
THAT WILL PROVIDE THE BLUEPRINT
FOR WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IN
THE FUTURE.
I KNEW WITHOUT A DOUBT OF THIS
IS THAT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING LOTS
OF CRUCIAL ISSUES.
THE ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
HERE RIGHT IT'S NOT THE ONLY
ONE.
BUT SUCH AN IMPORTANT ONE IS
THAT BILLION DOLLAR QUESTION THE
BILLION DOLLAR ISSUE. AND MAKING
SURE WE DEFINE THE MONEY THAT WE
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
GROUPS HAVE FOUND WAYS TO. TO
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND
THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
SO I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE PRESENTATIONS I'M GLAD TO
BE PART OF THIS GROUP.
OF VERY DISTINGUISHED.
.
CHAMPIONS FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
THAT.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT.
WITH THAT WE'LL BEGIN BEFORE WE
HAVE ARE OUR PANEL TODAY WE
WANTED TO. ALLOW.
A FEW INDIVIDUALS TO JUST GIVE
US A FLAVOR OF OF WHY I PRE QUE
IS SO IMPORTANT EARLY EDUCATION
FROM. AT THE GROUND LEVEL HERE
IN THE CAPITAL CITY OF
SACRAMENTO MY HOMETOWN OF COURSE
EXCITED SEE MY LOCALS HERE WE
HAVE OUR NEW SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT JORGE AG
ALLOWED.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY AND DONNA HOFFMAN.
CONAN WHO'S THERE CAMPAIGN
DIRECTOR OF EARLY LEARNING FOR
MOMS RISING. AND HOPE THAT AREA
MAMA TO.
PRE CARES AS WELL SO I THINK
YOU WILL START WITH THAT YOU
JORGE. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
HERE THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON TO EVERYONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND TO EVERY ONE OF OUR
COMMISSIONERS.
I'M I'M VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE
MY NAME IS HOKEY LOT. I'VE THEIR
PRIVILEGE IN HONOR OF SERVING AS
SUPERINTENDENT OF SACRAMENTO
CITY.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OUR
DISTRICT IS MADE UP OF SEVENTY
SEVEN SCHOOLS WITH OVER FORTY
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND WE OPERATE EARLY CHILDHOOD
CENTERS AT FORTY FIVE OF THOSE
SCHOOLS ARE THOSE ARE.
IN THE FORM OF EARLY HEAD START
AHEAD STARTS THE PRESCHOOL HEAD
START PRESCHOOL.
AS WELL AS A STATE SUBSIDIZED
AND PHOEBE SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN
CENTER.
AND ANY COMBINATION THEREOF WE
SERVE.
ABOUT EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE STUDENTS SUCH A SHY
OF TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS AREN'T
AT. A THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND I WANNA JUST SPEND A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT.
SEXY HE'S GUIDING PRINCIPLE
WHICH IS THAT.
ARE WE ARE DETERMINED TO GIVE
EVERY STUDENT AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO GRADUATE.
WITH THE GREATEST NUMBER OF POST
SECONDARY CHOICES FROM THE
WIDEST ARRAY OF OPTIONS.
NOW THAT'S A GUIDING PRINCIPLE
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED IN THAT
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO AND I
WILL BE THE FIRST TO ADMIT THAT
THE FOCUS ON POST SECONDARY
CHOICES SOMETIMES HAZARDOUS.
FOCUSED ON THE BACK END OF OUR
CONTINUUM THAT IS HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE GRADUATE MORE
STUDENTS THAN ARE GRADUATING.
AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
MORE OF THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE
GRADUATING ARE COMPLETING THE
ATG COURSE PATTERN.
I'M BUT I'M HERE TO ARGUE.
THAT WE HAVE TO SPEND AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE NOT DOING AS
EFFECTIVELY ON THE FRONTEND.
AND THAT WHAT WE'RE NOT DOING
ON THE FRONT AND WE PAY FOR ON
THE BACKEND.
SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT OF INFORMATION.
TO PROVE AT THIS POINT.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED.
THAT WE HAVE.
INITIATED A FULL REDESIGN OF
WHAT USED TO BE KNOWN AS OUR
SUMMER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
SUMMER SCHOOL USE TO BE A
PROGRAM THAT WAS AGAIN FOCUSED
ON MAKING SURE THAT MORE
STUDENTS GRADUATED THOSE THAT
WEREN'T ON TRACK TO GRADUATE.
NOT BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF CANDOR READINESS.
THIRD GRADE READING THIS.
TRANSITION YEARS OF SIX TO SEVEN
EIGHT TO NINE.
A WE HAVE REDESIGNED OUR SUMMER
SCHOOL PROGRAM.
FOCUSED ON A PHILOSOPHY OF
OPTING OUT. WHICH MEANS THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
CURRENT CANDOR STUDENTS THAT
AREN'T ON TRACK TO DEMONSTRATE
CANDOR READINESS.
AND WE'VE NOW GONE BACK FURTHER
AND IDENTIFIED THOSE STUDENTS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
DEMONSTRATE CANDOR READINESS WHO
DID NOT ATTEND AN EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM.
AND ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE STRUGGLING DID
NOT ATTEND AND EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM.
NOW.
AGAIN. WE COULD CHOOSE TO INVEST
THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES WE HAVE.
AT THE BACK END TO MAKE SURE
MORE STUDENTS GRADUATE BUT WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
AND I LIVE ON THE MANTRA THAT
EVERY SYSTEM IS PERFECTLY
DESIGNED TO GET US THE RESULTS
THAT HE GETS.
SO WE HAVE TO FUNDAMENTALLY
SHIFT THE PARADIGM.
FOCUS A GREAT DEAL OF ATTENTION
ON THE BACK END BUT BEGIN TO
FOCUS MORE ATTENTION ON THE
FRONT AND WHICH IS WHY I'M VERY
PROUD THAT OUR BOARD OF
EDUCATION. HAS FULLY COMMITTED
TO FUND A THIS VERY UNIQUE
SUMMER SCHOOL PROGRAM THAT WILL
SERVE STUDENTS AS EARLY AS
KINDERGARTEN WHO ARE NOT ON
GRADE LEVEL.
GOING INTO FIRST GRADE IN THE
FALL.
DUFF HOPPED OUT PHILOSOPHY
ENTAILS UP THE PRINCIPLE THAT WE
HAVE NOW NOTIFIED EVERYONE OF
THE PARENTS AND GUARDIANS OF
THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING AS KINDERGARTENERS.
THAT WE'VE ESSENTIALLY PRE
REGISTERED THEM FOR SUMMER
SCHOOL.
AND WE HAVE TO DO RECEIVED AN
OPT OUT FORM FROM A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN FOR US NOT TO SEE THE
STUDENT DURING THE SUMMER.
BUT WE ARE CONVINCED AND
COMMITTED THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT STUDENTS START THEIR FALL
SEMESTER DAY ONE IN THE FALL.
CLOSER TO GRADE LEVEL READINESS
GOING INTO KINDERGARTEN AND
FIRST GRADE. THAT THAT WILL SAVE
US.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES BOTH
HUMAN AND CAPITAL AS THE
STUDENTS PROGRESS IN THEIR
CAREERS.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT YOU SAID
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS WHICH IS A
FUNDING.
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS HAS
INCREASED OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS.
I IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ARE THE TOTAL AMOUNT
WE INVESTED WAS TWENTY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
SERVE JUST SHY OF TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
IT WAS TWENTY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SERVE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE STUDENTS ABOUT A HUNDRED
FEWER STUDENTS.
AND IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
EXPECT THAT COST TO BE ALMOST
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN FACT WE ARE SLATED TO INVEST
ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM
OUR GENERAL FUND. TO COVER THE
DIFFERENCE IN COST.
TO RUN THE SAME LEVEL OF
PROGRAMMING.
NOW WE ALSO KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE A WEIGHT LIST.
THROUGHOUT SACKS CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AS WELL. ARE AND
IT PAINS ME WHEN I LEARNED THAT
A STUDENT IS UNABLE BECAUSE OF
CAPACITY ISSUES PRIMARILY DUE TO
FUNDING. NOT TO ENROLL IN AN
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAM GIVEN THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE HAVE MADE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
DEMONSTRATING CANDOR READINESS
FIRST GRADE READINESS AND THIRD
GRADE READING CLASS.
AND I'LL JUST LEAVE YOU WITH
THAT FACT THAT IF FIFTY PERCENT
OF OUR STUDENTS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING DID NOT
ATTEND AN EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM.
IN THE URBAN SETTING MOST OF US
WOULD CELEBRATE IT FIFTY PERCENT
OF OUR STUDENTS COMPLETE THE ATG
COURSE PAT.
THAT'S A VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS STILL WANTING TO.
BUT I WOULD MUCH PREFER TO SEE
US NOT HIT A PLATEAU IN THAT
FIFTY PERCENT.
CELEBRATE BECAUSE WE'RE HITTING
EIGHTY NINETY PERCENT EIGHTY G.
COMPLETION RATES MATCHING OUR
GRADUATION RATES AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THAT IF
WE INVEST. MUCH MORE HEAVILY ON
THE FRONT AND.
THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
PRESENTATION.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH SOMEONE
NUMBER MCCARTY.
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMISSION
FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
MENTIONED I AM A LOCAL MOM OF
TWO AND MY NAME IS DONNA COLIN
AND I'M ALSO CALIFORNIAS
CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR FOR EARLY
LEARNING.
WITH MOMS RAISING WE ARE A
MILLION MEMBER GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION CAMPAIGNING
POLICIES. OF THAT STRENGTH AND
WOMEN CHILDREN FAMILIES AND OUR
ECONOMY WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW HUNDRED
THOUSAND IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
NUMBER FOR US HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND IT'S THE NUMBER OF INTO
INFANTS AND TODDLERS WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. TO HIGH QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES DUE
TO FUNDING AND A LACK OF SPACE
AND NOT THE REASON WE'RE ALL
HERE TODAY.
MOMS RAISING IS SO APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
WAS FORMED TO STRENGTHEN
POLICIES THAT LIFT UP
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGEST LEARNERS.
AND WE KNOW THE PARENTS IN THE
GOLDEN STATE DESPERATELY NEED A
BOOST AND CHANGED ABOUT SUPPORT
THEIR CHILDREN.
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE CHILDCARE ARE
AND PRESCHOOL ARE CRITICAL IN A
WINDOW OF TIME WHERE EIGHTY
PERCENT OF A CHILD'S BRAIN HAS
DEVELOPED. YET IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A CRISIS OF BOTH ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY.
RIGHT NOW ONLY FOURTEEN PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE INFANTS
AND TODDLERS AGES ZERO TO TO
HAVE ACCESS TO PUBLIC SUPPORTED
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE
OPPORTUNITIES.
FORCING THE PARENTS TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE
THEY LEAVE THEIR CHILDREN WHEN
THEY GO TO WORK.
COMPOUNDING THAT THE PRICE OF
INFANT CARE IN CALIFORNIA COSTS
FAMILIES MORE THAN IN STATE
COLLEGE TUITION.
WHICH A BARRIER SO HIGH THAT
MANY FAMILIES JUST BASS HORRIBLY
CHALLENGING DILEMMAS FOR CARE.
AND THE PRICE TAG ON CHILDCARE
CARRIES EVEN MORE TROUBLING WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE IMPACT ON LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
HEARING HELP CALIFORNIA FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR LIVING NEAR THE
POVERTY LEVEL.
IT WOULD TAKE NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THEIR MONTHLY INCOME
FOR CHILDCARE FOR TWO. WHICH IS
JUST UNACCEPTABLE AND
UNATTAINABLE FOR ALL FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH OVER TWENTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S KIDS
LIVING AT OR NEAR THE POVERTY
LEVEL OUR STATE DESPERATELY
NEEDS CHANGE.
WE STAND AT A MOMENT OF
UNMATCHED OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS ALL
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND OUR
STATE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SIXTY PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA'S EARLY LEARNING
SPEAK MORE THAN ONE LANGUAGE AT
HOME.
AND WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
CREATE EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WORK AND MEET
THE NEEDS FOR ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES.
INCLUDING ACCESS TO BILL
LANGUAGE LEARNING IN THE
EARLIEST YEARS.
OUR STATE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
BEACON FOR CHANGE AND PROGRESS
OFTEN THE EXAMPLE THAT OTHERS
POINT TO. YET UNFORTUNATELY OUR
COMMITMENT TO OUR YOUNGEST KIDS
DOES NOT ALWAYS LEAD THE WAY.
EVEN OUR ECONOMY RANKS SIXTH
LARGEST IN THE WORLD CALIFORNIA
STILL HAS THE SECOND WERE
STANDARD OF LIVING FOR CHILDREN
IN THE NATION. BUT CALIFORNIA'S
GROWING AND STRENGTHENING
ECONOMY MEANS THAT IT'S TIME FOR
US TO PUT OUR YOUNGEST KIDS
FIRST.
AND FILL THAT VOID THAT WAS
CREATED FOR CHILDCARE FUNDING
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
IT'S ALSO NO SURPRISE THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
PRODUCE A THIRTEEN PERCENT.
YOUR RETURN ON INVESTMENT
THROUGH IMPROVED RESULTS IN
EDUCATION HEALTH SOCIAL
BEHAVIORS AND EMPLOYMENT.
I'M HAPPY TO SEE SUCH A
PASSIONATE COMMITTEE GROUP OF
CHAMPIONS HERE TODAY WITH THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
AND I LOOK FOR TO THE GREAT
WORK THAT COMES IN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
SETTING THE STAGE THAT WE HAVE A
PANEL COMING UP OF A RESEARCHER.
PRACTITIONER AND ACADEMIC WE'RE
LOOKING FOR HEARING THAT BEFORE
THAT WE WENT TO ALLOW. ARAFAT
ARE SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY.
WHO TWO YEARS AGO WE WERE
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS BUDGET FOR
EASY HE THOUGHT YOU KNOW WHAT WE
NEED TO STEP UP AND INVEST MORE
BUT THINK MORE ABOUT THE LONG
TERM? WE CAN DO TO LOOK AT OUR.
FRAMEWORK CONSISTENCY IN
CALIFORNIA SO A SPEAKER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND I WANNA OBVIOUSLY
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARDIO IN
A WELCOME.
ALL OF THE COLLEAGUES THE
COMMISSIONERS PRESENTERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS.
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE AND FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
THE WORK OF THIS COMMISSION AND
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT OBVIOUSLY
TOO EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
THERE'S.
A A LOT OF FAMILIAR FACES.
OUT IN THE THE AUDIENCE I KEVIN
I MET.
A LONG TIME AGO WHEN WE WERE
BOTH WORK IN EARLY CHILDHOOD IT
EDUCATION SO IT'S GOOD TO THE
IT IT JUST FEELS LIKE HOME.
YESTERDAY I SPOKE AT THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF FIRST
FIVE.
AND I NOTED THAT KNOWS TWENTY
YEARS FIRST FIVE HAS BEEN
ENORMOUS RESOURCE FOR.
PARENTS AND POLICY MAKERS HAVE
REALLY HELPED SHAPE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE VITAL
IMPORTANCE OF.
ZERO THREE FIVE.
IT'S AMAZING HOW FAR ATTITUDES
HAVE COME IT'S AMAZING HOW FAR
RESEARCH HAS COME NOT ONLY
RESEARCH WITH RESPECT TO.
TO WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AND SORT OF APPLIED RESEARCH
BUT RESEARCH WITH RESPECT TO.
THAT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND AND
ALL THOSE TYPES OF EFFORTS.
BUT WE STILL WANT TO DO.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
FINANCING
AND THAT'LL BE OBVIOUSLY THE
FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING.
THIS IS OUR FIFTH HEARING.
SINCE I ESTABLISH THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO. AND I'M
EXCEPTIONALLY PLEASED WITH THE
THE HARD WORK OF OF.
THIS COMMISSION AND ALL OF ITS
MEMBERS.
AND I'M EXCITED THAT THE
COMMISSION IS ON TRACK TO MAKE
SOME IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS
TO. THE LEGISLATURE EARLY NEXT
YEAR AND THAT THANKS FOR COMING
TODAY AND. LET'S GET ON WITH IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
OUR FIRST PRESENTER IS AN WE
BRING UP OUR OUR PANEL NOW
STATES CAN USE CUTS WHICH UP
THE.
NEED.
THANK YOU I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH.
LYNN CAROLEE. SEIGNEURIE
ECONOMISTS FROM RAND.
THAT WORK IN THIS FIELD FOR
QUITE AWHILE AND IT GREAT TO SEE
YOU AGAIN I BET YOU WHEN YOU'RE
DOING ANOTHER WASTE POWER POINTS
IF YEARS AGO SO.
YES IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INCLUDING ME IN THIS.
HEARING TODAY I'M GONNA BE
SPEAKING ABOUT.
A STUDY THAT WAS DONE BY THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
ENGINEERING AND MEDICINE.
AND THE REPORT WAS RECENTLY
ISSUED.
PAUL TRANSFORMING THE FINANCING
OF EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION.
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
ALONG WITH A.
FILIA WHERE. SYRIA CHAU IS ALSO
A NUMBER ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. PUT TOGETHER BY THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES AND
ENGINEERING AND MEDICINE TO
CONDUCT THE STUDY.
THIS WAS A NATIONAL EFFORT TO
LOOK AT THE FINANCING FOR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION BUT I THINK
MANY OF BOTH THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE RELEVANCE
FOR YOUR WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY MENTION
THAT THIS STUDY WAS SPONSORED BY
A NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES AND I THINK IT SPEAKS
TO THE FACT THAT THIS IS. AN
ISSUE THAT IS DEEPLY RELEVANT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BOTH AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUT
AS WELL FOR STATES AND
LOCALITIES.
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
STUDIES ALWAYS BEGIN WITH A
STATEMENT OF TASK AND I JUST
WANT TO BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE THAT
THIS EFFORT.
BY OUR COMMITTEE WAS DESIGNED
TO LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF
FINANCING FOR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FOR CHILDREN FROM
BIRTH TO KINDERGARTEN ENTRY.
WHERE THAT EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION WOULD BE ACCESSIBLE
AFFORDABLE TO FAMILIES AND OF
HIGH QUALITY?
AND DELIVERED BY A WELL
QUALIFIED IN ADEQUATELY
SUPPORTED AND COMPENSATED
WORKFORCE
CONSISTENT WITH THE VISION AND
AN EARLIER NATIONAL ACADEMY
STUDY WHICH MANY OF YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH CALL TRANSFORMING
THE WORKFORCE. FOR CHILDREN FROM
BIRTH TO EIGHT.
SO ALL THAT STUDY SPECIFICALLY
LOOKED AT THE WORK FORCE FROM
BIRTH TO EIGHT.
THIS STUDY IS GOING TO BE
SPECIFIC TWO CHILDREN PRIOR TO
KINDERGARTEN ENTRY.
THE VISION ON THE PART OF THOSE
THE COMMITTEE THAT PRODUCE THE
TRANSFORMING THE WORKFORCE
REPORT.
WAS TO ACHIEVE HIGH QUALITY
PRACTICE
IN THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
SETTING.
ACQUIRED HIGH QUALITY
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NEEDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT THE
KNOWLEDGE AND COMPETENCIES OF
PRACTITIONERS AS WELL AS THE
LEADERS AND. THE SETTINGS WHERE
THEY DELIVER EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION.
PRACTICE ENVIRONMENTS AND
WORKING CONDITIONS THAT PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES AND TOOLS NEEDED
TO
PORT THE WELL BEING OF
PRACTITIONERS IN THE C. FEEL. AS
WELL AS SUPPORT OF POLICIES FOR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND THE
PRACTICE ENVIRONMENT.
SO WITH THOSE UNDERLYING VISION
FOR WHAT TO HIGH QUALITY WELL
COMPENSATED WORKFORCE WOULD LOOK
LIKE. OUR TASK WAS ESSENTIALLY
TO LOOK AT WHAT THE COST WOULD
BE.
TO PROVIDE A SYSTEM THAT
DELIVERED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION BIRTH TO KINDERGARTEN
ENTRY AS WELL AS TO THINK ABOUT
ISSUES FOR HOW ONE WOULD FIND
THAT SYSTEM. AND THE MECHANISMS
BY WHICH ANY RESOURCES REYES TO
SUPPORT SUCH A SYSTEM WOULD BE
DELIVERED.
SO WHAT TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
TERMINOLOGY TO CONSENT THE STATE
FOR EFFORT.
FIRST OF ALL BY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION I'M REFERRING TO PAID
NON PARENTAL CARE AND EDUCATION
PROVIDED OUTSIDE THE HOME FOR
CHILDREN. INCLUDING CHILD CARE
AND EARLY LEARNING SETTINGS.
ACROSS THAT ZERO TO
KINDERGARTEN INTERFERE EIGHT
FIVE SPECTRUM.
SO THIS IS INTENDED TO COVER THE
PAID CARE THAT'S RECEIVED IN
BOTH CENTER BASED SETTINGS AS
WELL AS HOME BASED SETTINGS.
AND SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE WORK FORCE IN THOSE
SETTINGS WERE REFERRING TO THE
PRACTITIONERS THEMSELVES WORKING
AND HOME ON SATURDAY SETTING
SUCH AS EDUCATORS. LEAD TEACHERS
FOR EXAMPLE THEIR ASSISTANCE OF
AIDS AS WELL AS ADMINISTRATORS
IN THOSE SETTINGS SUCH AS
DIRECTORS AND THOSE WHO SUPPORT
THE WORKFORCE AND THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
COACHES AND MENTORS.
AND THE UNITED STATES THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE CARE FOR CHILDREN FROM
BIRTH TO KINDERGARTEN ENTRY.
WITHIN THOSE CENTERS ARE ABOUT A
MILLION PAY YOU SEE WORKFORCE
MEMBERS AND ADDITIONAL MILLION
MEMBERS OF EASY WORKFORCE
PROVIDE CARE. ON AN EARLY
LEARNING AND HOME BASED SETTINGS
SO ARE STUDIES INTENDED TO APPLY
TO THOSE APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLION PRACTITIONERS IN THE
FIELD. PROVIDING PAID CARE
THROUGH HOME AND CENTER BASED
SETTINGS.
ANOTHER TERM THAT I WANTED TO
FINE IS.
WHAT WE REFER TO AS FINANCING
MECHANISMS
THESE ARE THE METHODS BY WHICH
FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED TO
ENTITIES STAKEHOLDERS IF YOU
WELL IN THE SYSTEM WHETHER THEY
BE PROVIDERS? OR FAMILIES THE
WORK FORCE OR THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT FUNDING MECHANISMS
THAT ARE PROVIDER ORIENTED. IT
MEANS MECHANISM SUCH AS
CONTRACTS ARE GRANTS WHERE THE
FUNDING COMES DIRECTLY TO
PROVIDERS HEAD START BEING
EXAMPLE IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
TOTAL FIVE PROGRAMS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT MECHANISMS
THAT ARE ORIENTED TOWARDS FAMILY
THOSE ARE CASES WHERE YOU WOULD
HAVE VOUCHERS OR TAX BASE
PREFERENCES SO THAT FAMILIES ARE
THE RECIPIENTS.
IF YOU WILL OF THAT THE.
SUBSIDY TO PAY FOR EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION.
THEY'RE ALSO EXAMPLES OF
MECHANISMS THAT ARE DIRECTED TO
THE WORK FORCE.
SUCH AS.
VARIOUS KINDS OF GRANTS ARE
STIPENDS THAT MAY BE USED TO
SUPPORT THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS TARGETED.
PAY INSIDE OF SUCH AS WAGE
GIVEN LEVEL OF EDUCATION. AND
SYSTEM WIDE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MECHANISMS THAT ARE DIRECTED
SUPPORT LARGER SYSTEM EFFORTS
LIKE QUALITY RATING IMPROVEMENTS
SYSTEMS DATA SYSTEMS AND SO ON
THAT AFFECT THE ENTIRE. I'M ECT
SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN IN THESE
AGES.
ONLY THINK ABOUT THE
LANDSCAPING.
LANDSCAPE PRINT CONCERT
CURRENTLY IN TERMS OF EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION AND FINANCING.
AS I KNOW YOU ARE WELL VERSED
IN THESE ISSUES NOW WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT HAS OF MULTIPLE
SOURCES. OF FUNDS RAISED AT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS
THROUGH SEPARATE PROGRAMS WHERE
THOSE PROGRAMS OFTEN HAVE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS WITH RESPECT
TO.
QUALITY ELIGIBILITY.
WHICH TYPES OF PROVIDERS CAN
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS OF ITS
PROVIDE ORIENTED.
AND A VARIETY OF WAYS IN WHICH
THE SYSTEM TODAY IS EXTREMELY
COMPLEX.
IN ADDITION.
FUNDING COMES NOT ONLY FROM THE
PUBLIC SECTOR BUT FAMILIES
CONTRIBUTE AS WELL AND BY OUR
ESTIMATE NATIONALLY FAMILIES ARE
CONTRIBUTING ABOUT FIFTY TWO
PERCENT. OF THE COST OF
PROVIDING EASY FOR CHILDREN FROM
BIRTH OUGHT TO KINDERGARTEN
ENTRY.
I THINK ANOTHER THING TO POINT
OUT TERMS OF FAMILIES
CONTRIBUTIONS THE DATA WE
EXAMINE AND REPORT ON IN OUR
REPORT. SO THAT THE LOWEST
INCOME FAMILIES.
WHO CONTRIBUTE TOWARD ECT WHEN
THEY DO SO?
IT'S TYPICALLY A HIGHER SHARE OF
THEIR INCOME COMPARED TO HIGHER
INCOME FAMILIES AND OTHER WORDS
THE BURDEN IS GREATEST ON THOSE
FAMILIES WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD.
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE COST OF
HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION.
IN DOING OUR WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE WE ESTABLISHED A SET
OF PRINCIPLES FOR HIGH QUALITY
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION.
THAT ARE PROVIDE A FOUNDATION
FOR US BOTH TO EXAMINE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IDENTIFY WHERE
THERE WERE GAPS OR SHORTFALLS
BUT ALSO TO GUIDE A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ALL TALK
ABOUT.
THAT I'LL TALK ABOUT LATER WE
ALSO VIEW THESE PRINCIPLES AT
ONCE AS ONE TO THE RELEVANT FOR
OTHER ENTITIES AN UNDERTAKING
THE KIND OF WORK THAT WE DID ON
OUR COMMITTEE. TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE COST OF THE
SYSTEM AND HOW ONE WOULD PAY FOR
IT.
SO I I THINK THESE MAY BE
RELEVANT FOR YOUR WORK AND
THINKING ABOUT ON THE OBJECTIVES
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
I'LL SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT.
THE SIX PRINCIPLES.
THE FIRST PRINCIPLE SAYS THAT
HIGH QUALITY EASY REQUIRES A
DIVERSE CONFIDENT EFFECTIVE WELL
COMPENSATED AND PROFESSIONALLY
SUPPORTED WORKFORCE ACROSS THE
VARIOUS ROLES OF THE E. C. E.
PROFESSIONALS.
THE SYSTEM FAILS TO MEET THIS
PRINCIPLE IN SEVERAL WAYS.
FIRST OF ALL.
AS I'M SURE YOUR WORK AS SHOWN
IN THE WORK THAT WE DID ON OUR
COMMITTEE SHOWS COMPENSATION FOR
EASY PRACTITIONERS IS LOW.
AND THAT'S TRUE WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TEACHERS WITH
BACHELOR'S DEGREES.
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO PUT PLAY
SUPPORTIVE ROLES ON THOSE IN
LEADERSHIP ROLES. AND THAT'S A
DRAWBACK IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY
TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN THAT
WORKFORCE THAT WE NEED IN ORDER
TO DELIVER THE HIGHEST QUALITY.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR CHILDREN.
SECOND OF ALL THE CURRENT WORK
FORCE ORIENTED FINANCING
MECHANISM SUCH AS THE KINDS OF
SUPPORTS THE CALIFORNIA HAS HAD.
TO ENCOURAGE THOSE.
MIGHT NOT HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE FOR EXAMPLE TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
THOSE FINANCING MECHANISMS DO
NOT CREATE PREDICTABLE AND STUDY
SOURCES
TO EITHER BOOST THE SALARIES.
OF THE LOAD COMPENSATED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FIELD AS WELL
AS TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN THEM.
SO THAT WE BILL THAT HIGH
QUALITY WORKFORCE
AND THEN FINALLY WHERE WE HAVE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDES THOSE
THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE UPON THE RATING IMPROVEMENTS
SYSTEMS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
FOR COACHING MENTORS AND SO ON
THOSE SUPPORTS ARE ALSO ONES
THAT.
ARE NOT SUSTAINABLE PROVIDED ON
A LIMITED BASIS SO AGAIN THEY
DON'T NOT REACH THE. ENTIRE
WORKFORCE IN A WAY THAT.
ENCOURAGES A BELT THAT HIGH
QUALITY WORKFORCE.
THE SECOND PRINCIPLE STATES THAT
HIGH QUALITY EASY REQUIRES ALL%
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO HAVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO AFFORDABLE
EASY ESERVICES ACROSS ALL ETHNIC
RACIAL SOCIO ECONOMIC AND
ABILITY STATUSES AS WELL AS
ACROSS GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS.
AGAIN OUR CURRENT FINANCING
STRUCTURE FEELS TO ACHIEVE ON
THE SUBJECT OF.
I MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO THAT
FAMILIES CURRENTLY PAY FOR ABOUT
FIFTY TWO PERCENT OF THE TOTAL
COST OF THE CD. AND FAMILIES
WITH THE LOWEST INCOME SPEND
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT OF THEIR
INCOME ON THAT CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING WELL FAMILIES AT THE
HIGHEST INCOME LEVELS PAY ONLY
ABOUT SIX PERCENT OF THEIR
INCOME.
SO WE HAVE THIS INVERTED SYSTEM
OF FAMILIES LEAST ABLE TO PAY
PAYING A LARGER SHARE OF THEIR
INCOME.
EVEN FOR FAMILIES WHEN THEY
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED UC'S SUCH
AS THEIR HEAD START OR IN
CALIFORNIA TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS
OR SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE.
THOSE FAMILIES ARE NOT BUT NOT
ALL FAMILIES WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
ABLE TO RECEIVE.
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE THE FUNDING
SIMPLY IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO
SERVE ALL FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY.
AND THEN FINALLY THE LACK OF%
HARMONIZATION ACROSS DIFFERENT
FUNDING MECHANISMS WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HEAD START. STATE
CHILDCARE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
AND OTHER STATE FUNDING SUCH AS
TITLE FIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
THOSE.
MECHANISMS.
LEAD TO GAP IN AFFORDABILITY
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES AS WELL
AS UNDER UTILIZATION BY MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES MANY OF WHOM
WOULD NOT QUALIFY BUT STILL FACE
THE SAME ISSUES ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY. AND THE ACCESS TO
EASY.
.
THE THIRD THROUGH SIXTH UP
PRINCIPLES RATHER THAN GOING
INTO DETAIL I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THAT EFFECTIVELY THEY
SPEAK TO ENSURING ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CARE AND A RANGE OF
SETTINGS.
AND HERE IN PARTICULAR THE
PRINCIPLES FOCUS ON THE NEED FOR
ADEQUATE AND SUSTAINABLE
FINANCING WITH INCENTIVES.
EQUALITY AND LOVE THE WORDS
LINKING FINANCING TO HIGH
QUALITY.
FINANCING FOR A VARIETY OF
SERVICE DELIVERY OPTIONS THAT
MEANS.
A SYSTEM THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
MIXED DELIVERY SUCH A CENTER
BASED AND HOME BASED SETTINGS.
AN ADEQUATE FINANCING FOR
FACILITIES AND FOR THE SYSTEM
LEVEL SUPPORTS THAT ARE NEEDED.
THOSE ARE OFTEN NEGLECTED
ASPECTS WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
FINANCING FOR ASSIST.
AND THE CURRENT SYSTEM AGAIN
FAILS TO MEET THESE REMAINING
PRINCIPLES IN SEVERAL WAYS.
FIRST OF ALL PROCEED A FINDING
TYPICALLY IS NOT TIED TO QUALITY
MANY OF OUR FUNDING STREAMS.
ARE NOT EXPECTING FAMILIES TO
BE ABLE TO USE THEM IN HIGH
QUALITY SETTINGS OR LINK THE
RECEIPT OF.
PARTICULAR.
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CARE TO THE
QUALITY OF THE OF THE PROVIDER
THE SETTING.
SECOND WHILE THE LEVEL OF
SUPPORT THAT IS PROVIDED TO
PROVIDERS WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOME OR CENTER BASED
SETTINGS IS TYPICALLY NOT
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE COSTS OF
HIGH QUALITY.
SO EVEN IF A PROVIDER HAS A
FUNDING MECHANISM THAT'S
ORIENTED TOWARD DEMOCRATIC
CONTRACT FAMILIES HAVE VOUCHERS
TO PAY FOR CARE OFTEN THE
REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS TO SET
THROUGH THOSE MECHANISMS THAT
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT TO COVER.
BECAUSE OF HIGH QUALITY.
AND FINALLY.
IN MANY RESPECTS WE DON'T HAVE
FINANCING OR FUNDING STREAMS
THAT SUPPORT THE SYSTEM LEVEL.
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED.
TO PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DATA AND
OTHER WAYS IN WHICH WE SEE THAT
WE HAVE A SYSTEM LEVEL ON HIGH
QUALITY SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
ACCESS TO FAMILIES AND A WELL
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE.
SO ANOTHER OBJECTIVE.
FOR OUR COMMITTEE WAS TO
DEVELOP AN ESTIMATE OF THE COST
OF DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY CD
WITH A WELL COMPENSATED
WORKFORCE. AT A NATIONAL LEVEL
NOT GONNA SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
OUR PROCESS.
OR OUR PARTICULAR NUMBERS
BECAUSE.
THEY WERE DEVELOPED TO BE A
NATIONAL ESTIMATE RATHER ONES
CIVIC TO CALIFORNIA. BUT I THINK
THE EXERCISE THAT WE WENT
THROUGH PROVIDED SOME IMPORTANT
FINDING SO I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
AND ALSO TO INDICATE THAT THE
PROCESS THAT WE USE.
STRATEGIES THE APPROACHES THE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE ONE THE AT A
STATE OR LOCAL LEVEL COULD BE
REPLICATED TO SEE WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE.
BEYOND THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
ESTIMATING THE COST FOR HIGH
QUALITY ECT AT A NATIONAL LEVEL
WE HAD SEVERAL OBJECTIVES ONE
WAS TO ACCOUNT. NOT ONLY FOR ON
SITE BECAUSE OF THE COST OF A
PROVIDER WHETHER TO CENTER HOME
BASE SETTINGS. BUT ALSO TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE SYSTEM WHITE
BECAUSE
I'M INTO YOU CAN SEE ON THIS
CHART THE KINDS OF ON SITE COSTS
THAT WE WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE. SO STAFFING AS A MAJOR
COST ELEMENT IN PROVIDING ECT
BUT ALSO.
TYING THAT TO ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
STAFF QUALITY AND THEIR
COMPENSATION.
OTHER ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORTS.
THE FACILITIES THEMSELVES FOR
EXAMPLE AND THAT AT THE SYSTEM
LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
QUALITY ASSURANCE AND
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS DATA SYSTEMS
AND SO ON. SO AGAIN THE GOAL IS
TO BE.
AS COMPREHENSIVE AS POSSIBLE
AND WE ALSO WANTED TO TIE OUR
ESTIMATES TO.
THE FINDINGS OF THE
TRANSFORMING THE WORK FORCE
REPORT IN TERMS OF ESTABLISHING.
TYPE OF HIGH QUALITY STAFF THAT
WE WERE IN VISIONING AS WELL AS
THE COMPENSATION TO GO WITH IT.
SO JUST TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
ABOUT THAT WE ASSUME THAT OUR
SETTINGS THAT WE WOULD HAVE LEAD
EDUCATORS WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AS.
CONSISTENT WITH THE TRANSFORMING
REPORT THAT THOSE EDUCATORS
WOULD HAVE ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THEIR DEVELOPMENT
THREE RESOURCES FOR COACHING
MENTORING AND SO ON.
THAT THE PROFESSIONAL STAFF
WOULD HAVE PAID RELEASE TIME TO
ALLOW THEM TO ENGAGE IN THIS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
THAT THERE WOULD BE RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AND HOME SATURDAY SETTINGS
AND THAT.
PROVIDERS WOULD HAVE NON CHILD
CONTACT TIME THAT WOULD BE USE
FOR EXAMPLE FOR PLANNING FOR
SUSPECTS OF CHILDREN FOR MEETING
WITH PARENTS WAYS IN WHICH THEY
WERE SUPPORTED THAN THOSE
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES.
WE DID COME UP WITH THE NUMBER
OF SO FOR THOSE OF YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN THE REPORT OUR ESTIMATE
NATIONALLY FOR THE U. S. ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS WAS THAT THE COST
OF A HIGH QUALITY EASY SYSTEM.
WOULD BE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS.
NOW FOR SOME THAT MAY SEEM LIKE
A LARGE NUMBER OTHERS IT MAY BE
HARD TO PLACE IN CONTEXT I THINK
ONE WAY TO. CONTEXTUALIZE IT IS
TO SAY THAT.
OVER THE FOUR PHASES IN WHICH
WE ENVISION THE SYSTEM BEING
PHASED AND BY THE TIME YOU GET
TO THE FINAL PHASE OR THE THE
END GOAL.
THE SYSTEM WOULD BE SPENDING
ABOUT THE EQUIVALENT OF POINT
SEVEN FIVE PERCENT OF US GDP ON
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION. THIS
IS JUST ABOUT THE AVERAGE FOR
OTHER HIGH INCOME COUNTRIES IN
THE OECD. SO THIS IS CERTAINLY A
REASONABLE ESTIMATE GIVEN WHAT
WE SEE OTHER HIGH COUNTRIES
DOING IN TERMS OF THEIR
INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA.
IN ADDITION WE CAN ALSO PLACE IN
THE CONTEXT OF K. TWELVE
EDUCATION.
SERVING CHILDREN FROM THE AGE
VAN FROM ZERO TO KINDERGARTEN
ENTRY REPRESENTS.
IN THIS CASE ABOUT.
.
ONE THIRD AS MANY CHILDREN AS
ARE SERVED IN THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM.
YET WE WITH.
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE
SPENDING ABOUT TWENTY TWO
PERCENT AS MUCH AS THE K.
TWELVE.
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE SUSPENDED
FEWER RESOURCES PER CHILD THAN
WHAT WE SEE IN THE CASE.
TO TWELVE YEARS.
ANOTHER CONSIDERATION ONCE WE
HAVE THAT ESTIMATE OF A HUNDRED
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS WAS TO
THEN INVESTIGATE HOW ONE COULD
THINK ABOUT. OF THE SOURCES OF
FUNDING TO PAY FOR THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION.
AND OF COURSE ONE SOURCE IS THE
PUBLIC SECTOR WHETHER THAT BE
FEDERAL STATE OR LOCAL FUNDING
BUT WE ALSO ONE TO CONSIDER THE
POSSIBILITY THE FAMILIES WOULD
CONTRIBUTE MUCH AS THEY DO NOW.
TO EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
ALMOND THE RIVER IDEA FOR
APPROACHES FOR FIGURING OUT
WHAT'S AN APPROPRIATE OR
AFFORDABLE ABOUT FOR FAMILIES TO
PAY.
OF COURSE ONE APPROACHES THERE
WOULD BE NO FEES FOR FAMILIES.
THINK ABOUT IS OUR CURRENT K.
TWELVE EDUCATION PUBLICLY FUNDED
K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
ONE COULD HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN FROM BIRTH
TO FIVE.
BUT ASSUMING THAT FAMILIES WERE
TO CONTRIBUTE.
THEIR NUMBER OF WAYS TO THINK
ABOUT THE FEES AND WE DID THAT
BY CONSIDERING FAMILIES PAYMENTS
AT THE LOWEST INCOME LEVEL WOULD
BE NOTHING.
AS A WAY NOT TO HAVE ANY
BARRIERS TO THEM BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN HIGH QUALITY
EASY.
AND THAT FAMILY PAYMENTS AS A
SHARE OF THEIR INCOME WOULD RISE
AS INCOME INCREASED YOU COULD
THINK OF THIS AS A PROGRESSIVE
SYSTEM. FOR OIL ALLOWING
FAMILIES TO CONTRIBUTE BUT DOING
SO AS A SHARE OF THEIR INCOME
WHERE THAT SHARE WOULD START OUT
LOW. AND GRADUALLY RISE AS
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT SYSTEM I
TALKED ABOUT WHERE WE SING THE
HIGHEST FAMILY PAYMENTS AT THE
LOW END AND DECLINING AS FAMILY
INCOME RISES.
SO.
OUR REPORT THEN SHOWS.
ESTIMATES OF WHAT THE SHARE
WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR FAMILIES.
WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR THE
PUBLIC SECTOR WHAT I WANT TO
CONCLUDE WITH OUR?
SOME OF THE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT I THINK ARE PARTICULARLY
RELEVANT.
FOR YOUR WORK BOTH AROUND
FINANCING AND AROUND THE
WORKFORCE.
I AM THE REPORT DOES HAVE A TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TOTAL.
I WANT TO SPEAK TO A FEW OF
THEM THEY ARE GROUPS.
BY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO AN EFFECTIVE
FINANCING STRUCTURE.
SHARING THE COSTS OF THE
CONTRIBUTION WOULD BE EXPECTED
POTENTIALLY FROM FAMILIES FOR
PLANNING FOR A TRANSITION FROM
THE CURRENT SYSTEM TO ONE THAT
WOULD HAVE.
A MORE EQUITABLE.
SUSTAINABLE FINANCING SYSTEM
WITH A HIGHLY QUALIFIED
WORKFORCE.
TRANSFORMING THE WORK FORCE
ITSELF AND THEN RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND ASSESSING PROGRESS IN
QUALITY.
SO AGAIN I WANT TO JUST FOCUS ON
A FEW OF THESE.
GIVEN TIME BUT WOULD BE HAPPY
TO TALK ABOUT OTHERS I'M IN THE
FOLLOW UP.
FIRST OF ALL WITH RESPECT TO
HAVE AN EFFECTIVE FINANCING
STRUCTURE THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION. UMBER FIRST OF
THE FACT THAT WE EXPECT THERE
WOULD BE A ROLE FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO ESTABLISH
CONSISTENT STANDARDS FOR QUALITY
SO THAT WE HAVE A MORE UNIFIED
SYSTEM AND THE WAY THAT WE
APPROACH.
SUPPORT FOR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION THAT FINDING WOULD BE
TIED TO QUALITY. REGARDLESS OF
THE FUNDING MECHANISM THAT IS
USED AND THAT STATE AND FEDERAL.
FINANCING MECHANISMS.
SHOULD ENSURE THAT PROVIDERS
ARE RECEIVING PAYMENTS THAT ARE
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE TOTAL
COSTS OF THESE ARE THREE ISSUES
THAT I ADDRESSED EARLIER. IN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM THAT NEED TO BE.
RECTIFIED.
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION SPEAKS
TO.
FINANCING WITH RESPECT TO
AFFORDABILITY FOR FAMILIES.
IN THIS CASE ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATION HERE WAS THAT
FAMILIES WOULD NOT BE EXPECTED
TO RECEIVE ACCESS TO SUBSIDIES
FOR EASY. BASED UPON THEIR
EMPLOYMENT STATUS IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM RECEIPT OF SOME FUNDING
IS TIED TO EMPLOYMENT SUCH AS
CHILDCARE SUBSIDIES WHEREAS
OTHERS ARE NOT HEAD START STATE
FUNDED PRE K. PROGRAMS DO NOT
TYPICALLY. A LOOK AT A FAMILY'S
EMPLOYMENT STATUS IN DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY.
SO WE THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT
THAT UP EMPLOYMENT STATUS NOT BE
A CRITERIA FOR ELIGIBILITY. OF
RECEIVING A PUBLIC SUBSIDIES.
WE ALSO HAD A THIRD
RECOMMENDATION LOOKED TO STATES.
IN PARTICULAR AS A MECHANISM
FOR.
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES FROM A
SYSTEM WHITES PERSPECTIVE AND
THAT STATES WOULD BE MUCH
ENGAGED IN A PROCESS MUCH LIKE
YOU ARE HERE. OF DEVELOPING.
THE MECHANISMS THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR CURRENT
SYSTEM SPEAK TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
TOWARD THE TYPE OF SYSTEM THAT
WE.
ENVISION.
WITH RESPECT TO COSTS ADAM AND
SHARING THE COSTS THE
CONTRIBUTION ON THE PART OF
FAMILIES.
WE RECOMMENDED THAT FINDING
WHETHER IT BE AT THE FEDERAL
STATE OR LOCAL LEVEL WOULD BE TO
INCREASE IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE
HIGH QUALITY SYSTEM THAT WE
ENVISION. AND THAT IF WE EXPECT
FAMILIES TO CONTRIBUTE THAT IT
WOULD BE DONE IN SUCH A WAY THAT
FAMILIES AT THE LOWEST INCOME
LEVEL. WOULD PAY NOTHING TOWARD
THE COST OF CARE AND THE SHARE
THAT THEY WOULD CONTRIBUTE WITH
RISE WITH INCOME MUCH IS THE
SYSTEM THAT WE MODEL THOSE AT.
ILLUSTRATIVE EXAMPLE.
WE DO I ENVISION A PLANNING
PROCESS IN OUR ESTIMATES OF WE
DO NOT ASSUME YOU COULD ACHIEVE
THE TYPE OF SYSTEM WE ENVISIONED
OVERNIGHT. ALMOND SO THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION SPECIFICALLY FOR
PROPHECIES.
TO WORK TOWARD THAT
TRANSFORMATION.
WITH RESPECT TO THE WORK FORCE.
WE RECOGNIZED THAT.
THERE'S A NEED BOTH TO THINK
ABOUT THE INCUMBENT WORKFORCE AS
WELL AS FUTURE WORKFORCE
MEMBERS.
AND SO WE WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED FOR THE
WORK FORCE TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
WITH RESPECT TO.
INCREASING KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPETENCIES IN THE FIELD.
WHETHER THAT'S THROUGH
PROSECUTIONS THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS
AND OTHER SUBFORUMS OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING.
AND IN PARTICULAR THAT THE
INCUMBENT WORKS FOR SHOULD NOT
BE BURDENED WITH THE COSTS OF
ACHIEVING THAT IMPROVEMENT IN
THEIR SKILLS QUALIFICATIONS AND
CALLED.
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT
EXISTING EDGE PART OF THAT
WORKFORCE TRANSFORMATION THAT
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT. WOULD BE
AB TARGETED SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
INCUMBENT WORKFORCE TO DEVELOP
THEIR QUALIFICATIONS.
AND.
THAT OTHER SUPPORTS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FINANCIAL AND
OTHERWISE FOR THE WORKFORCE.
THAT IS.
MOVING INTO THE FIELD IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE NOT
UNDULY BURDENED WITH THE COST OF
ACQUIRING THE EDUCATION AND
SKILLS THEY NEED. AS THEY MOVE
INTO THE FIELD PARTICULARLY WHEN
THE ISSUES OF COMPENSATION ARE
ADDRESSED THE SHOULD BECOME LESS
OF A NEED BECAUSE THE
COMPENSATION WILL BE SUFFICIENT.
AND RECOGNITION OF THE DEGREES
AND COMPETENCIES OF THE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD.
WE ALSO HAD RECOMMENDATIONS
SPECIFIC TO THE INSTITUTION'S
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
AND THE NEED TO BOOST THEIR
QUALITY AS WELL AS THE FINANCING
OF THOSE SYSTEM. SO THINK OF
THESE AS THE ISSUES AROUND
CURRICULUM AND THE PARTICULAR
SETTINGS WHERE.
EASY PRACTITIONERS AND.
THE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
SYSTEM ACQUIRED THEIR SKILLS AND
LEARNING.
AND LIKEWISE THAT STATE.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
NEED INSIDE OF US.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
PROGRAMS ARE OF HIGH QUALITY.
I HAVE FINALLY WE HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THE LARGER
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
THE SUPPORT FOR RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION TO ASSESS WHETHER OR
NOT A TRANSFORM SYSTEM IS
ACHIEVING ITS GOALS. AS WELL AS
OTHER DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED TO MONITOR AND ENSURE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE SYSTEM
THAT WE ENVISION.
SO IN SOME I THINK HE MESSAGES
THAT COME OUT OF THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES REPORT.
INCLUDE ARE WELL FOUNDED
UNDERSTANDING NOW THAT HIGH
QUALITY YOU SEE IS CRITICAL FOR
CHILDREN'S POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT.
AND HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
GENERATE I'M SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC RETURNS THAT OUR
CURRENT FINANCING STRUCTURE IS
INADEQUATE TO SUPPORT. THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF A
HIGH QUALITY RESEARCH I
WORKFORCE AND TO INCENTIVIZE
MOVEMENTS TOWARD HIGHER QUALITY.
THAT OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS AN
ADEQUATE WITH RESPECT TO
ENSURING THAT ALL CHILDREN HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY EASY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR FAMILY
BACKGROUND. AND TO FINALLY THAT
THE TOTAL COSTS OF PROVIDING.
ACCESS TO THE TYPE OF AFFORDABLE
HIGH QUALITY SYSTEM THAT WE
ENVISION IS ONE THAT WILL INDEED
NEED NEW RESOURCES FROM THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. EVEN IF WE EXPECT
FAMILIES TO CONTINUE TO PAY A
SHARE OF THOSE COSTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
DISCUSSION THAT FOLLOWS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL STOP
HERE AND AND ENTERTAIN COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ON THIS
PRESENTER. WE CAN
SEAT.
YES COMMISSIONER OWNIK.
SEEMS LIKE TO ASK YOU QUESTIONS
IN WASHINGTON AND THEN ASK YOU
QUESTIONS IN SACRAMENTO. SO.
.
IT IN YOUR COMMENTS IN UNION
PRESENTATION.
I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING ABOUT
FAMILY FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
AND IN TALKING TO SELL YOUR SHE
SAYS THERE WAS INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT AND I WONDER IF YOU COULD
COMMENT ON.
THE WHOLE NOTION OF IMPROVING
QUALITY AND INTIMATE FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS WHICH IS A REALLY VERY
INTIMATE KIND OF THING THAT GOES
ON.
BECAUSE THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
SO THEY CAN THE ISSUE IS FAMILY
FRIENDLY CARE AND I ASSUME BY
THAT.
.
I IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THOSE.
CARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE UNPAID.
AND THOSE THAT ARE PAID SO OUR
STUDY DID IT INCLUDE HOME BASED
CARE. THAT'S PROVIDED COULD BE
FAMILY FRIEND OR NEIGHBOR BUT IS
IF IT'S COMPENSATED CARE PAID
CARE. THAT IS COVERED BY OUR
WAYS ONE ALL OVER ESTIMATES OF.
THE.
NUMBER FAMILIES THAT USE CARE
THE AMOUNT OF CARE THAT THEY USE
FOR INFANTS TODDLERS AND
PRESCHOOLERS ALL WERE BASED ON
ESTIMATES THAT INCLUDED HOME
BASE SETTINGS FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR CARE. IT COULD ALSO BE
THOSE WHO ARE FORMALLY LICENSE
TO PROVIDE CARE AND HOME BASED
SETTING SUCH AS.
UP FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES SO
THAT RANGE OF PAID CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE HOME BASE
STUDIES IS CAPTURED. WHAT IS NOT
CAPTURED OUR IS THE PART OF THE
WORK FORCE THAT IS
UNCOMPENSATED?
AND SOME OF THAT MAY BE
PROVIDED IN HOME BASE SETTINGS A
CHILD'S HOME OR ANOTHER.
INDIVIDUALS HOME AND THAT WAS
JUST PARTLY A LIMITATION IN A
CONSTRAINT ON OUR WORK IN THAT
WE WERE CHARGED WITH LOOKING AT
THE PAID SYSTEM.
NOW IT'S ENTIRELY.
POSSIBLE WITH THE TRANCE
FORMATION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THAT WE WOULD DRAW
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
EASY WORKFORCE SOME OF WHOM MAY
BE CURRENTLY PROVIDING
UNCOMPENSATED CARE. AND THAT
THOSE SAME OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
DESCRIBE FOR.
BECOMING A WELL QUALIFIED
MEMBER OF THE PAID WORKFORCE
WOULD BE OPEN TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CURRENTLY TODAY.
MAYBE PROVIDING CARE IN THOSE
SETTINGS ON UNCOMPENSATED BASIS.
WE HAVE SOME UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT MIGHT CHANGE IN TERMS OF
FAMILIES USE OF CARE SO IF WE
ELIMINATE THE BARRIERS OF THE
TERMS OF THE COST OF CARE TO
FAMILIES WE MAY EXPECT TO SEE
MORE FAMILIES. MOVE INTO THE
MORE FORMAL PART OF RTC SYSTEM
WHICH POTENTIALLY HAS THE
ADVANTAGE OF.
MOVING CHILDREN INTO THESE
MONITORED REGULATED. QUALITY
SYSTEMS
MANY FAMILIES THOUGH MAY STILL
CHOOSE TO USE CARE THAT.
UNCOMPENSATED FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR CARE ALMOND THAT'S
GONNA BE A FUNCTION OF THEIR
UNDERLYING NEEDS FOR CARE THEY
MAY BE USING A COMBINATION.
OF CARE FROM THE MORE FORMAL
SYSTEM IN THE INFORMAL SYSTEM
DEPENDING UPON THEIR NEEDS.
SO I I HOPE THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHERE IT'S
CAPTURED AND WHY WE WOULD EXPECT
THE SYSTEM IN A COMPLETE SYSTEM
TO CONTINUE TO INCLUDE.
SOME OF THE INFORMAL CARE THAT
WE SEE IS THAT.
YES COMMISSIONER EMISSIONS AND
AGAIN IT. TO THIS.
YES.
COME.
WHAT A FOLLOWUP BECAUSE I DIDN'T
REALLY HEAR THE PIECE ABOUT?
EXEMPT CARE PROVIDERS INCLUDED
IN THE HOME BASED A SETTING SUN
GLAD TO HEAR THAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE.
THEY ARE YES IT JUST AGAIN TO
REFLECT THERE'S A MILLION
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PROVIDE CARE
AND HOME BASED SETTINGS.
THAT WERE INCLUDING IN OUR VIEW
OF THE SYSTEM SO ONE THING I AM
I WANTED TO. YOU KNOW ALSO LIFT
UP BECAUSE YOU ALSO SAID YOU
WANNA DE DE LINK EMPLOYMENT WITH
NEED AND ACTUALLY I REALLY.
AGREE WITH THAT.
.
BUT THE JOBS THAT A LOT OF
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
THESE JOBS THAT ARE IN.
RESTAURANTS RETAIL HOSPITALITY
MEDICAL FIELDS HOME HEALTH
AIDES.
AND.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THESE HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
ARE NOT OFFERED. SORT OF.
DURING THOSE NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS ON NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS
WITH SCHEDULES THAT ARE VARYING.
SO HOW WHEREIN THE VISION OF
THIS E. C. E. SYSTEM DO YOU SEE
A PLACE FOR A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF FAMILIES.
WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT REFLECT?
THERE.
I THINK IT A COUPLE ANSWERS THE
QUESTIONS AROUND THE.
NEED FOR NON STANDARD CARE FIVE
HOURS.
FIRST OF ALL.
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
DESCRIBING DOES STILL INCLUDE
HOME BASED CARE SO FAMILIES WITH
THOSE NEEDS FOR NONSTANDARD
HOURS MAY CONTINUE OR MAYBE YOU
DON'T CHOOSE TO USE HOME BASED
CARE PROVIDERS. AND AGAIN THIS
IS
A SYSTEM THAT WE'RE ENVISIONING.
WHERE IF YOU'RE IN THE PAID
HIGH QUALITY WORKFORCE THAT IN
YOU CHOOSE AS A PROVIDER TO
OFFER CARE DURING THOSE
NONSTANDARD HOURS THAT WOULD BE?
YOU KNOW PART OF WHAT THE SYSTEM
IS THAT WERE ENVISIONING.
I THINK ANOTHER ASPECT OF.
.
THE SYSTEM THAT WE ARE.
SCRIBING IS WHY AND WHERE
BECAUSE PROVIDERS WOULD BE
COMPENSATED FOR THEIR COST OF
CARE.
THAT.
WE WOULD EXPECT PROVIDERS TO
OFFER MORE OPTIONS FOR CARE
DURING NON AMHERST NONSTANDARD
HOURS RECOGNIZING THE COST OF
THAT PROVISION AND ONE BARRIER
NOW. IS THAT IT'S HARDER FOR
PROVIDERS TO DIFFERENTIATE AND
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT TO REFLECT
THOSE DIFFERENTIAL COST.
SO WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT WILL BE AND NEED ON THE
PART OF FAMILIES WILL CONTINUE
I'M A SIMILAR KINDS OF ISSUES
AND MORE WORLD SIGHTINGS VERSUS
URBAN SETTINGS IN TERMS OF CARE
ACCESS AND AVAILABILITY. THAT
MEANS WE STILL WANT A SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS FOR A DIVERSE ARRAY
OF SETTINGS AND PROVIDER TYPES.
WE JUST WANT TO SEE THAT IT'S
HIGH QUALITY.
AND DELIVERED BY HIGH QUALITY
WORKFORCE AND ONE WHERE THAT.
WORKFORCE IS WELL COMPENSATED
PROVIDERS ARE COMPENSATED FOR
THEIR CAUSE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACE.
Q. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
IN MUCH THE LITERATURE AND THAT
THE CHIU. FRAT ON YOU YOU TALK
ABOUT.
THIS LEVERAGING AND IT WAS ONE
OF YOUR CONCLUSIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS
SEVEN.
SPECIFICALLY.
ON LEVERAGING EXISTING FUNDING
SOURCES AT THE STATE LEVEL.
TO ENHANCE QUALITY FOR THE EASY
WORKFORCE.
IT IS OR SOMETHING THAT.
THAT THAT IS CALIFORNIA FUNDING
SPECIFIC THAT YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN
US ON.
WE CAN USE FOR THE LEVERAGING
GRANT PROGRAMS ARE THE LIFE
RIGHT SO WHAT I THINK THAT THE
BASIC GOAL THAT WE WERE.
THINKING ABOUT IN THAT
RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT WE
WANTED AS AS WE FIRST TRIED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT RESOURCES WERE
CURRENTLY IN THE SYSTEM AND THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM DOES HAVE
MULTIPLE FUNDING STREAMS FEDERAL
STATE EVEN AT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AND WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
TO SEE A SYSTEM THAT IS MORE.
HARMONIZED MORE UNIFIED BOTH IN
THE SIDE OF ESTABLISHING FOR
EXAMPLE STANDARDS FOR WHAT
CONSTITUTES QUALITY. BUT ALSO IN
THE WAY IN WHICH RESOURCES COULD
BE BETTER PULL TOGETHER. AND HE
USED FOR SUPPORTING THIS LARGER
SYSTEM BOTH FOR THE DIRECT CARE
PROVISION AS WELL AS LARGER
SYSTEM COSTS. AND FOR SUPPORTING
THE WORKFORCE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC MECHANISM IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
HAD IN MIND BUT THERE ARE SOME
STATES THAT ARE. PUTTING FORWARD
RESOURCES TO USE FOR PURPOSES OF
INVESTING IN THEIR WORKFORCE.
THAT MAY BE PART OF THEIR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE
WHERE THEY HAVE RESOURCES
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC TO.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
WORKFORCE TRANSFORMATION AND SO
WE WANTED TO SEE THAT THOSE
WOULD BE RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
CAPTURED AS WELL THE VALUABLE TO
THIS.
TO THIS LARGER CYSTS.
WHEN EXAMINING THE THE STATE'S
ROLE.
AS A COORDINATOR.
SORTS
FOR THE VARIOUS ENTITIES.
WORKING WITH THAT WITHIN THE DC
FIELD.
WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURES
WOULD WOULD NEED TO BE CHANGED
ARE PUT INTO PLACE?
TO MAKE THIS MORE EFFECTIVE.
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT OUR
COMMITTEE DID NOT GET DOWN TO
THAT LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY IN
TERMS OF WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK
LIKE A PART RECOGNIZING THAT
STATES OFTEN APPROACH THESE.
ISSUES AROUND.
SORT OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE.
WAYS IN WHICH.
.
THAT IS IS ESTABLISHED SO
EXAMPLES WOULD BE AROUND
GOVERNANCE ISSUES.
IN THE STATE'S NOW. THEY TO
EXTENT THAT STATES HAVE BEEN
INVESTING IN STATE PRE K.
PROGRAMS THE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES THAT THEY PUT IN
PLACE A VARIED QUITE
CONSIDERABLY WHETHER. THEY HOUSE
THAT IN THEIR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN THE SOCIAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT ESTABLISH A NEW
DEPARTMENT.
HAVE SOME WAY IN WHICH YOU KNOW
THAT EFFORT IS HOUSED WITHIN AN
OVERALL GOVERNMENT STRUCK.
SO WE RATHER VIEW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE STATES WOULD
DETERMINE WHAT ARE THE NEEDED
MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO ENABLE
THAT KIND OF COORDINATION.
AND HARMONIZATION OF A SYSTEM
AND SOME STATES MAY BE FAR
ENOUGH ALONG THAT THEY THINK
THEY ALREADY HAVE. THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE IN PLACE OTHERS MAY
NEED TO HAVE MORE TIME TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE.
AND AGAIN IT'S GOING TO DEPEND
APART THE HISTORY OF WHERE THEY
BEN. ALONG WITH WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER MAC
MILLAN.
THANK YOU REPRESENTATION
SO.
IT ONE OF YOUR KEY ASSUMPTIONS
YOU HAD. MENTIONED LEAD
EDUCATORS WITH BA DEGREES CAN
YOU TELL ME HOW THAT RELATES TO
FAMILY CHILDCARE.
SO AGAIN GOING BACK TO THE
TRANSFORMING REPORT.
THAT WAS OUR OUR FOUNDATION.
IN TERMS OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THEY SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDED
THAT GOING FORWARD IN WHETHER
YOU'RE AT HOME OR CENTER BASED
CITING THAT THERE WOULD BE A BE
A LEVEL. EDUCATOR AS PART OF THE
PROVISION OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION.
INFILL CHILD CARE SETTINGS.
THAT MAY TAKE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FORMS AND AND AGAIN I
THINK PART WE NEED TO LOOK TO
RESEARCH TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HIGH
QUALITY LOOKS LIKE IN THE
SETTINGS. SO IT MAY BE THAT IN A
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME WHERE YOU
HAVE A SMALL GROUP THAT PROVIDER
MAY HAVE. A BACHELORS LEVEL
DEGREE AND WHAT WE'RE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT IS COMPENSATION
THAT GOES ALONG WITH THAT.
ANOTHER MODEL BABY ONE WHERE YOU
HAVE GROUPS OF FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOMES WORKING TOGETHER. AND
SUPPORTING THE STRUCTURES SUCH
AS A BE A LEVEL.
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD BE
SUPERVISING OR SUPPORTING THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS IN
THEIR OWN HOMES IF THEY DO NOT
THEMSELVES HOW THAT LEVEL TO
CREATE.
I'M SO THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS IN
WHICH YOU COULD STRUCTURE THIS.
AND.
THAT BABY YOU KNOW STATE LEVEL
DETERMINATION OR A FUNDING
STREAM LEVEL DETERMINATION AS TO
WHAT THAT SPECIFICALLY LOOKS
LIKE.
WE HAD TO MAKE A NUMBER OF
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT RATIOS.
AT THINGS LIKE THAT IN COMING
UP WITH OUR ESTIMATES AND IN
DOING SO PARTICULAR WITH FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES WE WEREN'T
NECESSARILY ASSUMING. THAT HE
WOULD HAVE THAT BE A LEVEL STAFF
PERSON IN EVERY FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOME BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES WITH
RATIOS BUT IT COULD BE A SHARED.
MODEL LIKE THE ONE I WAS
DESCRIBING MAY I ASK.
WHO HOME IN?
WHAT RESEARCH WHAT GROUPS WERE
INVOLVED IN THIS DECISION MAKING
FOR FAMILY CHILDCARE?
SO THAT I REFER YOU TO THE
EARLIER NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES STUDY CALLED
TRANSFORMING THE WORKFORCE. THAT
WAS SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT THE
WORKFORCE SKILLS COMPETENCIES
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHAT A
HIGH QUALITY WORKFORCE WOULD
LOOK LIKE. OTHER EXTENSIVELY
REVIEWED THE LITERATURE AROUND.
EDUCATION LEVELS OTHER SKILLS.
AND TRAINING FOR THE WORK FORCE
AND THAT WAS THEIR CONCLUDING
RECOMMENDATION.
WHICH ARE COMMITTEE WAS THEN
GIVEN AS A.
A FOUNDATION THAT WASN'T UP TO
US TO.
RE DEBATE THAT CONSIDERATION.
OR OPEN BACK UP THE ISSUES THAT
WENT INTO THAT RECOMMENDATION I
I WOULD URGE YOU TO LOOK AT HOW
LOOK AT THAT REPORT MORE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
QUITE CONSIDERED.
IN TERMS OF THE EVIDENCE THAT'S
AVAILABLE NOW.
THE NEED FOR FURTHER
UNDERSTANDING AROUND THE ROLE OF
DEGREES VERSUS OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH WE.
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE IN TERMS
OF THEIR SKILLS AND COMPETENCIES
THROUGH PROFESSIONAL OTHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
MECHANISMS. AND THERE MAY BE
INDEED BE A PERIOD OF TRANCE
TRANSITIONING THE WORK FORCE
FROM OUR CURRENT WORKFORCE TODAY
MANY OF WHOM DO NOT HAVE THOSE
DEGREES PROTECTING FAMILY
CHILDCARE SETTINGS. TO ONES
WHERE THEY'RE PROVIDED WITH.
PORTS DURING A TRANSITION.
TO A WORKFORCE WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THOSE COMING
INTO THE WORKFORCE WOULD HAVE
THOSE HIGHER SKILLS AND
COMPETENCIES AGAIN WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND THE
SUPPORT FOR ATTAINING THOSE
DEGREES. AND THE COMPENSATION
THAT GOES WITH IT.
AND SO THAT I THINK IS A WAY OF
VIEWING THAT. COMBINATION OF
DEGREES
SUPPORT FOR DEGREES THE WORK
THAT YOU DO IN THE FIELD AND THE
COMPENSATION THAT'S RECEIVED TO
ALIGN THEM IN SUCH A WAY. THAT
WE CAN HAVE A HIGH QUALITY
WORKFORCE IN BOTH HOME AND
CENTER BASED SETTINGS.
HOME.
I GUESS YOU CAN TELL BY MY FACE
I'M NOT REALLY PLEASED WITH. THE
FINDINGS IN THIS AT BEING A
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER WHO
DOES NOT HAVE A BACHELORS WHO
HAS AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE SO
THIS WOULD THIS WOULD BE A MAJOR
UPHEAVAL IN THIS FIELD THAT I
LOVE SO MUCH. AND SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND OTHER FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE LOVE SO
MUCH AND SO THAT'S WHY I ASK YOU
WHO.
DID TO TALK TEN YOU REFERRED ME
BACK TO THAT THIS ASSOCIATION
AND THE STUDY AND I AM GOING TO
LOOK INTO THAT. BECAUSE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE FIND
IS CLEARLY REPRESENT.
FAMILY CHILDCARE AND MY SISTER
AND BROTHER NOW PROVIDERS WHO DO
THIS WORK EVERY DAY AND ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS WORK
SO ON BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING
THE MESSENGER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I THINK I GET
TERRIBLE INSTRUCTIONS BY
COMMISSIONERS WHAT I MEANT YEAH
QUESTIONS I'M A HORRIBLE TEACHER
RIGHT NOW LIKE GIVING
INSTRUCTIONS TO GIVE A QUESTION
LIKE THAT SO I KNOW WHO'S. WHO
TO ASK?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU YES.
MY COMMENTS ARE. IN LINE WITH
WHAT YOUR SAME BECAUSE I HAVE A
MANY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS THAT.
THAT DO PROVIDE EXCELLENT.
.
WITH KAREN EXCELLENT.
FOR AN EXCELLENT FOUNDATION FOR
THE KIDS NOW ARE AS A FORMER
TEACHER I CAN TELL YOU. EVEN IN
THE THE SCHOOL SETTING PRESCHOOL
TEACHERS ARE UNDER THE
CLASSIFIED.
DESIGNATION NOT NECESSARILY
CERTIFICATED AND THEN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CERTIFICATE
A POSITION VERSUS.
CLASSIFIED IS ABOUT. INC HE WE.
IT'S THE BE.
COMMON CORE MATH.
IT'S ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS DIFFERENCE AND IF YOU
HAVE A BACHELORS DEGREE AND I'M
ME BEEN OUT OF SCHOOL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE NINE STORE.
PAYING MY MY STUDENT LOANS AYE
I'M TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR MY
FAMILY AND ON TOP OF THAT PAY
FOR STUDENT LOAN IF WORK.
I HAVE ADDITIONAL BURDENS.
BECAUSE IT REALLY AT. THE DEGREE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY PROVIDE A
MAKE SOMEBODY PROVIDE THAT
BETTER.
EDUCATION OR BAR.
SERVICES.
.
THERE IS A BIG DISCONNECT AND I
FEEL LIKE IN THE GAME YOU ARE
ONLY THE MESSENGER BUT THE
COMMENT WOULD BE HIS.
BOB POLICING ADDITIONAL BURDENS
WOULD LESSEN THE POOL OF
QUALIFIED.
QUALIFIED AND PASSIONATE.
PROVIDERS AND SO HOW DO WE
RECONCILE THAT THE INFORMATION
IS GREAT AND WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THAT'S GREAT. AND THAT IS.
ALSO IN AN IDEAL WORLD AND WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN IDEAL
WORLD SO IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAY BE RECONCILED THAT
INFORMATION TO THE REALITIES OF
WHAT'S REALLY HAVE.
NOW WOULD BE GREAT
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION
APPRECIATE THE MESSENGER BUT I I
DO AGREE WITH. THE COMMENTS
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW WE CAN THE PLACE
THESE ADDITIONAL BURDENS. AND
ARE WE GONNA HAVE ENOUGH
PROVIDERS.
THAT MAKE THAT.
.
HOW DOES QUALITY?
SO I THINK THIS IS IN RESPONSE
THE THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT.
CAN LOOKING AT OUR
RECOMMENDATION SPECIFICALLY TO
THE WORKFORCE.
THAT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
REVOLVE AROUND NOT INCREASING
THE BURDEN ON THE WORKFORCE IN
TERMS OF DEGREE OPPOSITION.
SO WHY RECOMMENDATION WAS
SPECIFIC THAT THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY COME BUT MEMBERS OF
THE WORKFORCE WOULD PAY NO COST.
TOWARD ACHIEVING ANY DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAYBE AND A
NEW SYSTEM.
AND SECOND OF ALL THAT FOR
THOSE COMING INTO THE WORKFORCE
THAT THERE WOULD BE AN ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN WHAT THEY WOULD BE
EXPECTED TO CONTRIBUTE AND
THEY'RE EXPECTED SALARIES.
SO PARTICULARLY AND THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WITH COMPENSATION
THAT'S LOW IN AN ADEQUATE. THAT
WOULD IMPLY GREATER DEGREE OF
SUBSIDY JUST TO ACHIEVE THE
DEGREE OF PAYMENTS.
ONCE YOU SEE THAT
TRANSFORMATION THAT WE'RE
DESCRIBING HERE OF A WORKFORCE
THAT'S COMPENSATED.
ASSISTANT WITH THERE DEGREES
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
PRACTITIONERS.
EATING FOR EXAMPLE
KINDERGARTNERS IN A PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
THAT IF YOU HAVE EQUIVALENT
AGREES TRAINING COMPETENCIES
THAT YOU WOULD BE COMPENSATE
ACCORDINGLY.
THAT THAT WOULD THAT MIGHT
IMPLY MORE OF THE UP FRONT COSTS
REQUIRED FUSION MIGHT BE BORNE
BY THE INDIVIDUAL BUT WITH THE
EXPECTATION.
THAT THEY WOULD BE COMPENSATED
ACCORDINGLY JUST LIKE OTHER
MEMBERS INDIVIDUALS ATTAIN
HIGHER EDUCATION WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE FIELDS THEY
MOVE INTO. WILL ALLOW THEM TO
PAY BACK THEIR STUDENT LOANS AND
SO ON. SO I THINK.
THAT IT'S AGAIN IT'S THE
COMBINATION OF WHAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT EXPECTATIONS FOR
THE WORKFORCE AND THEIR SKILLS
AND COMPETENCIES ADAM.
DEGREES CREDENTIALS
THE COMPENSATION THAT GOES WITH
IT AND THAT WHATEVER SETTING
THEIR END. THAT THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT THROUGH ANY PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
COMPENSATION THE OTHER COSTS
ACCORDINGLY SO THAT HE WON'T
HAVE THE SHORTFALLS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY. THAT DON'T ALLOW FOR HIGH
QUALITY PROVISION BECAUSE.
THE.
THE REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURES
ARE NOT CONSISTENT WITH
PROVIDING PIPE.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER COMPASS
REBEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND I AM. AND AND I
I FEEL LIKE MY QUESTION HAS
ALREADY BEEN ANSWERED STILL BE
MORE OF A COMMENT I GUESS I AM
VERY HOPEFUL AND I THINK THAT
THE DATA THAT'S BEFORE US AND
RESEARCH AT THE FORCES. THAT ARE
REALLY HELPING FORMER THINKING
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME AREAS WHERE WE'RE GONNA
SCRATCH OUR HEADS A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND ONE BURKE HOW CAN WE.
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK AS WE TALK ABOUT BA'S
AND AND OUT WHEN THE
CHOOSE SHOULD HAVE.
AND AGAIN WEBER COMIN REINFORCE
WHAT'S JUST BEEN SAID I THINK IT
WAS A LUMINA FOUNDATION THAT PUT
TOGETHER REALLY GOOD STUDY ON
WHAT PRIOR LEARNING LOOKS LIKE
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY WITH
THIS BODY AND MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE GOING TO REALLY HAVE
TO GRAPPLE WITH. I'M AND REALLY
THINK ABOUT THOSE COMPETENCIES
AND IN ADDITION TO JUST THE BE A
AYE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S.
YOU DON'T TEACHERS ARE EARLY ED
TEACHERS PROVIDERS ITEM
CARETAKERS THAT HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS WORK FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
ARE FABULOUS THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BE A. AYE BUT IF IF WE GOT TO
OUR NORTH STAR BECAUSE WE SHOULD
THINK NORTH STAR I AGREE. I'M
SUCH AS WE TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE
OP AS WE HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT. PRIOR LEARNING AND THAT
AND REALLY TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
THAT LEVEL OF EXPERIENCE ON
THOSE YEARS OF WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE I YOU HAVE IN THE
YOU'RE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE. ARMS
I THINK THIS AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THIS BODIES IS
REALLY GOING TO HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH HOW DO WE INCORPORATE PRIOR
LEARNING. I MEAN REALLY INVITE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION AND
AND THE AUDIENCE REALLY LOOK AT
THIS REPORT AND AGAIN I THINK IT
WAS THE LUMINA FOUNDATION THAT
DID IT THAT LOOKED AT OTHER
SECTORS OUTSIDE OF EDUCATION AND
WHAT OTHER SECTORS BUSINESS
SECTORS. ARE DOING I'M IN
ADDITION TO JUST THE BE EIGHT
BUT THAT ARE GONNA PUT HIM UP
HIGH.
ON THE. SALARY PIECES WELL SO
THANK YOU.
COMMISSIONER WITH THE.
AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR THIS
REPORT I THINK IT'S VERY HELPFUL
I THINK ALL OF US UP HERE OF
TAKING THAT ONE HUNDRED FORTY
BILLION DOLLAR NUMBER IN TRYING
TO DO THE MATH AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT WOULD BE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT PUT FOUR BILLION ALRIGHT
THERE WE GO ONE PREFER REALLY
TEN BILLION?
A FABULOUS I'M I'M I'M CURIOUS
BECAUSE YOU TALKED IN THE VERY
BEGINNING ABOUT THREE BUCKETS
ALMOST RIGHT THE COST OF THE
EARLY KERN EDUCATION COSTS OF
THE WORK FORCE PEACE NET COST OF
THE STATE MECHANISM. OF IS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION DECIDE
WORKOUT IMPROPER IN IN WHAT
PERCENTAGE FALLS UNDER EACH
CATEGORY I'M CURIOUS I'M
PROBABLY IT YOU MAYBE YOU DIDN'T
DO IT OUT THAT WAY OR IF YOU DID
PERCENTAGE VERSUS PHASE AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS.
HOW THAT WORKED OUT ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL?
I CAN TELL YOU JUST OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD THAT THE SYSTEM LEVEL
COSTS WERE ABOUT EIGHT PERCENT
OF THAT NUMBER THE HUNDRED FORTY
BILLION DOLLAR NUMBER.
SO MOST OF IT IS IN THE DIRECT
CARE PROVISION.
HOW MUCH OF IT IS TIED TO FOR
THE WORK FORCE TRANSFORMATION
I'D HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK
BUT?
AGAIN IT'S GOING TO BE A
RELATIVELY SMALL SHARE MUCH OF
THAT IS THE DIRECT CARE
PROVISION
OKAY IF WE CAN GET THAT NUMBER
THAT PERCENT YEAH THAT WOULD BE
REALLY REALLY HELPED ALL THAT.
THANK YOU.
AND I WILL NOT THOSE OF A MATH
THERE SO CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT TEN
PERCENT GO SAY IT'S ABOUT THERE
WOULD BE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN FOR
GAMBLING.
YEAH BUT WE HAVE NO I DIDN'T A
CRAFTY BUT THAT'S IT. YEAH
HOUSING CITED A WE CAN DO ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION SUPPORT FOR
THE.
COMMISSIONER AYALA.
THANK YOU LIANE BECAUSE IT'S A
IT'S A VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE IT'S A BIG BIG PICTURE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO HAVE US THIS
COMMISSIONERS THINK OF
ASPIRATION.
THAT THIS IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
IF THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME I SEE
SOME FRIENDS.
I REMEMBER WHEN KIM THERE WAS
NOT A MANDATE IT IT STILL IS
NOT.
BUT WE'RE TEACHERS DID NOT HAVE
A CREDENTIAL. IN ITS TAKEN AS
ALL THESE YEARS TO GET HERE.
SO JUST A COUPLE BERMAN SAYS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE VERY
HEATED. AND I'M TALKING HEATED
DISCUSSION.
THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
DISPLACING THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE.
WE ACTUALLY NEED MORE.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NO COST
SHOULD BE INCURRED BY THE
EXISTING WORKFORCE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OVER TIME
PHASING IN OVER A MAY BE AT TEN
OR TWELVE YEAR.
PROCESS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT. MAKING
SURE THAT.
PEOPLE'S.
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE ARE
DISCOUNTED BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO NEED THAT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE CARED FOR AN
EDUCATED. AND WE KNOW THAT THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE. IF THEY CAN
DEMONSTRATE THROUGH COMPETENCIES
ARE PATHWAYS THAT'S A DECISION
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO ME.
THIS IS A NATIONAL REPORT. THAT
WAS BASED ON ANOTHER REPORT THEY
DID TALK SPECIFICALLY THAT A LOT
OF RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
GROW.
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL ASSOCIATION. AND A
LOT OF OTHER GROUPS IN TERMS OF
RESEARCH THAT HAD BEEN DONE WITH
HOME CARE.
IT WAS ALSO THE PREVIOUS REPORT
WAS NOT ONLY EDUCATION BUT IT
DEALT WITH SOCIAL WORK AND
HEALTH PROVIDERS. AS IT RELATED
TO THE ZERO TWO EIGHT
POPULATION.
SO I WANT US TO THINK.
NOT WHAT IS.
BUT WHAT SHOULD BE.
AND THAT WE THINK ABOUT NOT THE
BARRIERS TODAY. BUT HOW WE GET
THOSE.
PATHWAYS
CAREER PATHWAYS
ARE HARMONIZATION OF FUNDING.
IN THE WAY THAT GETS IS THERE
AND I WANNA GO BACK JUST TO TO
MISS THEM.
LAGOS A OR ACTUALLY IT WAS.
ELEVATIONS THEM RAISES
QUESTION THERE ARE SOME.
MODELS THAT ARE WORKING FOR US.
BUT THEY'RE SMALL. AND.
RIGHT NOW WE MIGHT BE INVESTING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY BILLION
BUT AS YOU SAID MR MCCARTY WE
NEED FOURTEEN MORE BILLION. AND
I THINK MICHAEL HAD TO ATTEND
BUT I LIKE YOUR NUMBER BETTER.
FOURTEEN BILLION TO GET US TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. BUT IT'S
GONNA BE OVER TIME
AND SO I I DON'T WANT US TO
BECOME DISCOURAGED.
I WANT US TO BECOMING COURAGE
AND EXCITED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES BECAUSE FOR ME
AFTER ALL THESE YEARS.
I SEE THE LIGHT.
I REALLY DO LOVE AT THAT TIME
THING WILL MAKE YOUR LIFE A JUST
A REMINDER THAT'S WHAT THIS BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSIONS ABOUT IS TO
LOOK AT THE NORTH STAR AND.
AND AND.
BE PROVOCATIVE IT THINK YOU
KNOW WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND
WHERE WE SHOULD BE BUT I BUT I
WILL NOTE THAT THESE THESE
ISSUES.
AS FAR AS THE EDUCATION LEVEL TO
BE A WE DO NOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT HEAD START BECAUSE THEY
ARE THEY'RE MAKING THIS CHANGE.
IN ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THAT
YOU BROUGHT UP WHAT WHY IT'S
HARD. IS BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE
IN THE FIELDS UP ONE THEY'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB YOU KNOW AND
IT.
A PUSH THEM OUT AS HAVING SOME
RECOGNITION AS YOU TRANSITION
WHETHER IT'S A GRANDFATHER
CLAUSE WHAT HAVE YOU BUT. SAY
IT'S HARD BECAUSE THERE ARE.
PEOPLE IN THE FIELD ARE GETTING
PAID YOU KNOW IN AND OUT BURGER
COSCO WAGES WILL FINALLY PAY
THOSE POVERTY WE JUST PRAY THAT
THEIR WORKFORCE AND SO.
I THINK THAT'S A PIECE TO AS WE
LOOK AT YOU KNOW PROPERLY.
SETTING OUR RATE STRUCTURE FOR
THE PROGRAMS.
THEN WE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ISSUE AND THEN I THINK YOU CAN
TACTIC TO TAKE A LOOK AT YOU
KNOW EDUCATION LEVELS AND WHAT
IT COSTS.
BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THE RESEARCH DOES SHOW
THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON QUALITY IF
YOU WANT.
GIVES THE SHOW UP IN YOUR FORMER
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM HERE RAY
LEARN DAY ONE. AND THIS IS A
REALITY OF SO.
WITH THAT AT GREAT BUT
PRESENTATION GOOD DISCUSSION WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO.
PROFESSOR.
MANY INDIAN.
CLOSE.
MELENDEZ MEANT OKAY IN INDIA YES
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AND.
PROFESSOR.
RESEARCH AT THE HOSPICE A TOOT
AT UC BERKELEY.
THANK YOU. AND WELCOME TO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONERS AND
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY.
NOT ONLY FOR HAVING US HERE BUT
FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
CRITICAL BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
OCCURS BEFORE AGE FIVE AND YET.
THE UNITED STATES RANKS TWENTY
SIXTH OUT OF OECD COUNTRIES IN
THE FRACTION OF FOUR YEAR OLDS
THAT ARE ENROLLED IN PRE K..
AND TWENTY FOURTH IN THE
FRACTION OF THREE YEAR OLDS.
BUT.
I'M NOT HERE TO PRESENT ON THE
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUE HIGH.
I'M HERE RATHER TO DISCUSS A
POLICY FRAMEWORK FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER.
THAT.
WE THINK MIGHT BE VERY HELPFUL
AS YOU CONSIDER YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND THAT FREE MARKETS WHAT SOME
FED A SCOTCH PAUL AND HARVARD
CALLS TARGETING WITHIN
UNIVERSALISM IN WHAT WE CALL. IT
THE HAWES INSTITUTE TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM.
SO THIS FRAMEWORK IS AN EQUITY
FRAMEWORK.
BUT IS NOT A POLICY AND DOES NOT
SUBSTITUTE FOR POLICY.
AND IN FACT IT'S NOT A STRATEGY
RATHER IT'S AN APPROACH BY WHICH
EQUITY STRATEGIES MAY BE
DERIVED.
AND IT ALSO EXPRESSES A
COMMITMENT TO BOTH PROCESS IN
EQUITY OUTCOMES.
IT'S AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
BINARY TRAP OF EITHER TARGETED
FOR UNIVERSAL POLICY SO I'M
GONNA TRY AND.
IF WE RUN THROUGH THOSE AND THEN
OPEN UP FOR.
SOME QUESTIONS.
PART OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
THIS TRAP OF TARGETED VERSES
UNIVERSAL.
IS CREATES A FALSE BINARY THAT
WE. THAT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
FIND OUR WAY THROUGH.
.
SO UNIVERSAL POLICIES ARE THOSE
THAT ASPIRE TO SERVE EVERYONE
WITHOUT REGARD TO GROUP
MEMBERSHIP STATUS ARE INCOME.
AND THEY TEND TO SET A UNIFORM
EITHER SET OF BENEFITS OR OUR
GOAL OR SET A MINIMUM
PROTECTIONS SO. FOR EXAMPLE
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS.
OR.
IN A.
THE.
.
THE POPULAR THING THESE DAYS IS
THE UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME WHICH
IS A IS A POLICY APPROACH THAT
WOULD. PROVIDE A BENEFIT THAT OF
EQUAL AMOUNT TO EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF INCOME SO THE
WEALTHIEST INDIVIDUALS WOULD
RECEIVE THE SAME BENEFIT.
IS THE POOREST.
AND SO THE IDEA OF UNIVERSAL IS
THAT IT IT REALLY MEANS
EVERYONE.
.
SO SOMETIMES POLICIES ARE
DEVISED THAT HAVE A UNIVERSAL
SCOPE OR FRAMING BUT ARE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO SOLVE THE
TARGETED PROBLEM THE FMLA IS A.
EXAMPLE OF THAT ITS ORIGINAL
IMPETUS WAS TO.
PROVIDE LEAVE FOR FAMILIES WITH.
.
WITH PREGNANT.
PARENTS PIG PARENTS AND NEW
PARENTS
AND. IN ITS ULTIMATE EXPRESSION
THE THE LAW ACTUALLY ALLOWED
ANYONE TO TAKE A LEAVE INCLUDING
CARING FOR ELDERLY PARENTS OR
SIBLINGS.
SO IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF A
UNIVERSAL APPROACH WITH A
TARGETED A TARGETED PROBLEM.
NOW ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
TART WITH UNIVERSAL APPROACHES
IS THAT UNIVERSAL APPROACHES.
ACTUALLY HAVE A TENDENCY IN MANY
INSTANCES TO EXACERBATE
INEQUALITY.
SO IN THE INITIAL CDC STUDY OF
THE MASSACHUSETTS UNIVERSAL
HEALTH CARE THE SO CALLED
ROMNEYCARE APPROACH.
THE CDC REALIZE THAT WHILE
EXPANDING INSURANCE COVERAGE TO
EVERYONE.
THE DIFFERENTIAL ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE ITSELF ACTUALLY
EXPANDED THE RACIAL GAPS
IN ACCESS TO CARE.
SO I CAN ASSURE YOU A COUPLE
SLIDES AND HOW THAT CAN MODEL
OUT.
.
THE FIRST ONE WE DEFINE WHEN WE
DEFINE TARGETED WOULD BE A
POLICY THAT TARGET
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS BASED UPON
THEIR CHARACTERISTICS ARE
DEMOGRAPHICS.
AND SO. IN THIS CASE THERE'S A
RECOGNITION THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM AND IN THE POLICY LUCIEN
POLICY PROPOSE OUR SOLUTION IS
TAILORED TO THAT PROBLEM.
SO EXAMPLES MIGHT BE THE
AMERICAN JUST WITH DISABILITIES
ACT WHICH NOT ONLY PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION REQUIRES EQUAL
TREATMENT. BUT ALSO REQUIRE
SPECIAL ACCOMMODATIONS INCLUDING
EASEMENTS ENTRANCES AND PARKING.
AND SO YOU CAN THINK ABOUT
DIFFERENT POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT
MIGHT FALL INTO THE UNIVERSAL
VERSUS TARGETED A FRAMEWORK SO
YOU COULD COMPARE. UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME WITH A NEGATIVE
INCOME TAX WHICH WOULD BE
CONDITION ON INCOME
OR.
SNAPPED VERSUS A SINGLE PAYER
APPROACH.
SO ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS A
ALREADY MENTIONED WITH EQUAL
TREATMENT A UNIVERSAL APPROACHES
IS THAT IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET
EVERYONE TO THE GOAL. SO THIS IS
LIKE A MEME THAT CIRCULATE ON
THE INTERNET QUITE A BEEN THERE
NUMBER OF. IMAGES LIKE THIS THAT
ILLUSTRATE THAT PROBLEM RIGHT
THAT EQUAL TREATMENT DOES NOT
ACTUALLY GET EVERYONE. TO THE
EQUITY OUTCOME.
SO HERE IS A HERE'S ANOTHER
SLIDE THE CAN SHOW HOW UNIVERSAL
PROGRAM CAN DO THIS.
SO I'M.
CONSIDER FOR EXAMPLE THAT YOU
HAVE TO GROUPS AND THEY COULD BE
RACIAL GROUPS GENDER GROUPS A.
ANY GROUP ANY ANY GROUP BASED
CHARACTERISTIC AND YOU HAVE A
UNIVERSAL PROGRAM. AND UNIVERSAL
PROGRAM IS A HE IS THE TREATS
THAT EXTENDS BENEFITS EQUALLY
INTRIGUES MEMBERS OF EACH GROUP
OF THE SAME.
BUT OF FOR MEMBERS IN THE SHADED
GROUPS A DAY LIVE IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT SAY FOR
EXAMPLE ARE ISOLATED FROM JOBS
AND SO JOB TRAINING PROGRAM
WOULD ACTUALLY FREE. THE PEOPLE
WHO NOW HAVE THE SKILLS TO
SECURE THE JOBS WHEREAS THE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE TRANSIT TO
THE JOBS WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE JOBS.
A WERE WHY THEY MAY HAVE THE.
THE HUMAN CAPITAL THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY ARE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
SECURE THOSE JOBS AND THIS IS
THE PROBLEM THE CDC IDENTIFIED
IN MASSACHUSETTS WHICH WAS THAT.
ACTUALLY HAVING INSURANCE
DOESN'T GIVE YOU ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
SO WHAT IS TARGETING
UNIVERSALISM AND HOW CAN
ACTUALLY SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
THIS IS A LOT OF TAX BILL FOR ME
TO SAY THAT BASICALLY IT'S AN
APPROACH.
THAT SUPPORTS THE NEEDS OF THE
PARTICULAR WHILE REMINDING US
THAT WERE ALL PART OF THE SAME
SOCIAL FABRIC
SO REJECTS A KIND OF UNIVERSAL
BLANKET THAT'S INDIFFERENT TO IT
TO HELP PARTICULAR GROUPS ARE
SITUATED IN SOCIETY.
IS AND IT ALSO REJECTS A KIND
OF
FORMA A FORMAL EQUALITY THAT
ACTUALLY.
CREATES A DISPARATE IMPACT.
SO IN ITS MOST SIMPLIFIED FORM
WHAT IT MEANS TO SETTING
UNIVERSAL GOALS AND PURSUING
THOSE GOALS WITH TARGETED
PROCESS HE'S
GONNA WALK YOU THROUGH A STEP BY
STEP.
FRAMEWORK TO SHOW HOW YOU DO
THIS.
SO THE FIRST STEP IS YOU HAVE TO
ESTABLISH THE UNIVERSAL GOAL
BASED UPON. A BROADLY SHARED
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROBLEM.
.
A SECOND THEN IS YOU ASSESSED
THE GENERAL POPULATION
PERFORMANCE TO THE UNIVERSAL
GOAL SO CAN BE ANYTHING BE. A
MATH PROFICIENCY COULD BE
INCLUDES A YEAH COULD ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY IT COULD BE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE COULD BE ACCESS
TO EARLY QUITE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION AND.
CHILDCARE
I'M SO THE FIRST THING YO DO IS
YOU NEED TO DO A KIND OF GENERAL
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT.
THE THIRD IS THEN YOU BEGIN TO
SEE THE LOOK AT SUB GROUPS AND
YOU IDENTIFY GROUPS AND PLACES
SO IT'S NOT JUST. UP COMMUNITIES
OUR POPULATIONS BUT YOU ALSO
NEED TO LOOK AT GEOGRAPHIES.
SEE HOW THOSE PLACES AND GROUPS
ARE PERFORMING RELATIVE TO BOTH
THE OVERALL POPULATION BUT
ACTUALLY MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
GOAL RIGHT BECAUSE THE GOAL
SHOULD NOT BE TO GET. YOU KNOW
ONE GROUP TO WHERE THE BEST
PERFORMING GROUP IS BUT RATHER
EVERY GROUP TO THE GOAL ITSELF.
RIGHT THAT'S ACTUALLY A KEY
DISTINCTION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT STEP IN A TARGET
PERSONAL SOME FRAMEWORK.
STOOD THEN ASSESS AND UNDERSTAND
THE STRUCTURES THAT EITHER
SUPPORT OR IMPEDE. EACH COOPER
COMMITTEE FROM ACHIEVING THE
GOAL SEAT ACTUALLY HAVE TO
CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS IT THAT'S
HOLDING FOLKS BACK.
NOW IT MAY BE BARRIERS IT MAY BE
CHALLENGES MAY BE A LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION IT MAY BE A LACK
OF SUPPORT. BUT IT MIGHT ALSO BE
THAN SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES
THEY ARE OTHER SORT OF PROACTIVE
OF AFFIRMATIVE STRUCTURES THAT
ALLOW FOLKS TO ADVANCE TO THE
UNIVERSAL GOAL SO IT'S NOT
ALWAYS A BARRIER SO MUCH AS IT
MAY THE ABSENCE OF RESOURCES OR.
OR CAPACITIES.
AND ONCE YOU DEVELOP AN
ASSESSMENT AND ANALYSIS THEN YOU
NEED TO BEGIN TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT TARGETED STRATEGIES
FOR EVERY GROUP.
SO IT'S A UNIVERSAL BLANKET
STRATEGY TO TREAT EVERYONE THE
SAME I ACTUALLY FAILED TO GET
YOU TO THE UNIVERSAL GOAL.
AND SO THIS IS ACTUALLY THE
CRITICAL PART AS YOU MIGHT HAVE
A MARRIED A PLETHORA OF
STRATEGIES.
BUT THOSE STRATEGIES ARE
NECESSARY TO GET EVERYONE TO THE
GOAL AND THAT IS THE HEART OF
THE TARGET PERSONAL SOME
FRAMEWORK.
FRAMEWORK IS A FOCUS ON
UNIVERSAL GOALS BUT TO
RECOGNITION THAT YOU NEED
TARGETED POLICIES TO
TO REACH THOSE GOALS.
NOT JUST A COUPLE OF CAVIAR ARE
NOTES ON THE FRAMEWORK.
TARGETING WITHIN A TARGET VERSE
WASN'T FRAMEWORK DOES NOT ALWAYS
MEAN TARGETING PEOPLE OR EVEN
POPULATIONS OFTEN DOES BUT NOT
ALWAYS OF COURSE THERE ARE.
LIMITATIONS WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
PROP TWO A NINE I COULD HAVE A
WHOLE SEPARATE SEMINAR IN ON
THAT.
BUT.
THE HEART OF TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM IS ACTUALLY
TARGETING INSTITUTIONS AND
STRUCTURES.
SO I CAN GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
.
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE PLACES
THAT HAS OPERATIONALIZED ORGAN
VERSOS AND IS THE CITY OF AUSTIN
AND TEXAS.
AND WHAT THEY DID WAS THEY
DIDN'T ASSESSMENT AND THEIR GOAL
WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
RESIDENT IN THE CITY.
LIVE WITHIN OUR HAD ACCESS TO
GREEN SPACE AND LIVE COULD COULD
LIVE WITH AND A HALF OR A
QUARTER MILE. OF OF THE PUBLIC
PARK
AND SO THEY THEY CREATED GIS MAP
IN THE ASSESSED WHERE RESIDENTS
LIVE RELATIVE TO THE GREEN
SPACES AND THEY CREATED NEW
GREEN SPACES RIGHT. THAT'S THE
INSTITUTIONAL APPROACH AS
OPPOSED TO MOVING PEOPLE YOU
ACTUALLY CREATE GREEN SPACE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE SO THE FOCUS
ISN'T ON PEOPLE PER SE IT'S
ACTUALLY ON THE INSTITUTION
STRUCTURE CONSISTS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
.
THE TARGET REVERSALS APPROACH
ALWAYS TARGETS.
INSTITUTIONS ARE STRUCTURES.
THERE WAS A PROGRAM A VERY
VALUABLE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTED IN
BALTIMORE CALLED VISION FOR
BALTIMORE.
IS A PROGRAM LAUNCHED BY THE
CITY HEALTH DEPARTMENT. BASED ON
A RECOGNITION THAT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM WHO NEEDED. A MEDICAL
CARE SPECIFICALLY NEED THAT
NEEDED CONTACT LENSES OR GLASSES
WEREN'T GETTING AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW THAT.
WAS A BARRIER TO ACTUALLY
LEARNING.
AND SO THEY PROVIDED HEALTHCARE
PROGRAM THAT BOTH SCREEN AND
THEN PROVIDED THAT.
THE PROVIDED THAT RESOURCE.
SO IN THAT CASE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CREATING INSTITUTIONAL PROGRAM
THAT DOES TARGET PEOPLE BUT
THE POINT IS THAT MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT A TARGET REVERSALS OF
APPROACH WILL FOCUS ON SYSTEMS
AND STRUCTURES AND INSTITUTIONS.
FINALLY IN IMPLEMENTING A TARGET
REVERSALS APPROACH.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU NOT JUST
BRING TOGETHER THE EXPERTS.
AND THE LEGISLATORS AND THE
COMMISSIONERS BUT YOU ACTUALLY
BRING TO GO THE PEOPLE FROM THE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE AFFECTED.
AND THAT YOU MONITOR THE
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
ACHIEVING THE OUTCOME AND YOU
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS OVER TIME SO
IMPLEMENTATION AND EVALUATION
ARE OUR VITAL.
AND THAT'S IT THERE'S A VIDEO
WHICH I AM A LITTLE A THREE
MINUTE VIDEO THAT JUST GOES OVER
THIS I WON'T SHOW YOU SHOW RIGHT
NOW BUT IF YOU'D LIKE TO LOOK AT
IT.
.
PLEASE PLEASE CHECK IT OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER NOBODY.
FULLER. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
THIS REPORT THIS SPEAKS TO OUR
HEART BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
EQUITY PERSONS EQUALITY.
IS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TONIGHT PARTICULARLY. I'M LOVING
THE FACT THAT THAT ANY OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO TALK TO PEOPLE. WHO
NEED THE SERVICES? IN ORDER TO
FIND OUT WHAT THEY NEED BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES IN OUR PROFESSIONS
WEEK KIND OF. FIGURE OUT THIS IS
WHAT PEOPLE NEED WITHOUT
ACTUALLY.
REACHING OUT TO THEM AND FINDING
THAT OUT SO THANK YOU THIS IS
THIS WAS GREAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET THE POWER.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER IGNATIUS.
I HAVE CLIENTS AMAZING.
.
I ACTUALLY LEARNED ABOUT
TARGETED UNIVERSALISM.
BECAUSE WE BROUGHT A GROUP
TOGETHER TO LOOK AT WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO BRING A RACE CLASS
AND GENDER ANALYSIS TO THE EASY.
SYSTEM AND IT WAS OUR INCREDIBLE
CONSULTED TAMMY JONES AND
HOPEFULLY YOU HEAR ME.
SHE RAISED TO US AND.
IT SO OFTEN THE CONVERSATION OR
NOT HAVING.
AND.
OFTENTIMES WE ARE CREATING
PROGRAMS THAT THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO WERE TRYING TO TARGET. UP
CANNOT GET TO AND THEN WE
PENALIZE THEM AND WE DEMONIZED
THEM FOR SOMEHOW NOT.
YOU KNOW JUMPING OVER OR THROUGH
OR UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOOPS TO GET TO IT AND I REALLY.
BELIEVE THAT THIS COMMISSION IS
REALLY COMMITTED TO TAKING THIS
APPROACH.
.
I HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
DO THAT.
AND THAT A FUTURE SYSTEM REALLY
CONSIDERS AND UNDERSTANDS WHAT.
THE NEEDS ARE OF AB WHO WE ARE
TRYING TO TARGET.
MY QUESTION TO YOU.
.
YOU KNOW WHERE SHOULD WE.
START.
WE TALKED ABOUT A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
DOING FOCUS GROUPS OF FAMILIES.
IF YOU WERE YOU KNOW.
ADVICE EVEN THIS COMMISSION WILL
I GUESS YOU ARE HOME WHERE WHERE
WOULD YOU TELL US TO START.
YES.
I THINK BOTH OF THOSE PLACES ARE
VITAL STARTING POINTS AND YOU
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T DO ONE
WITHOUT THE OTHER.
HE NEEDED YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
THE DATA AND SEE WHERE THE
POPULATIONS ARE THE SUBGROUP
RELATIONS ARE WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT YOU ALSO HAVE
TO DO THE QUALITATIVE SIDE YOU
HAVE TO MEET WITH GROUPS.
AND FIND OUT IS YOUR SPECIAL YOU
DEVISED THE STRATEGIES YOU KNOW
WHAT OF THE ACTUAL BARRIERS AND
STRUCTURES THAT ARE ALLOWING
SOME GROUPS TO ADVANCE THE
UNIVERSAL GOAL AND HOLDING
OTHERS BACK.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER MCMILLAN.
THE THANK YOU FOR THAT I HAD
NEVER HEARD OF TARGET
UNIVERSALISM SO YOU.
JUST EDUCATED ME ON THAT AND
NOT.
KNOWING THAT BEEN A PART OF THE
LABOR MOVEMENT.
WE COULD NOT ARE ALREADY DOING
THAT ESPECIALLY WOULD FAMILY
CHILDCARE BECAUSE WE WORK OUT OF
OUR HOMES AND SO FOR US TO.
EVEN FIND OUT ABOUT OUR UNION
AND AND AND WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
IT HAS TO BE.
IT HAS TO BE BROUGHT TO US.
IS THAT HOW IT WORKS IN MY IN MY
DOING A GOOD COMPARISON OR AM I
NOT.
WHAT I HAVE TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT
MORE BUT I I THINK THAT?
PART OF WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING
HERE IS THAT TO GET EVERYONE TO
THE GO TO THE UNIVERSAL GOAL
REQUIRES A MULTITUDE OF
STRATEGIES. AND ONE SIZE
ACTUALLY DOES NOT FIT ALL AND
THAT ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
THAT'S JUST
SINGULAR UNIVERSAL CAN ACTUALLY
EXACERBATE INEQUALITY CAN MAKE
THINGS WORSE.
AND SO I I APPRECIATED WHAT.
I GUESS I HAD TO SAY ABOUT
ABOUT.
.
HARMONIZING APPROACHES BUT ALSO
BEING FLEXIBLE AS
PART OF WHAT I HEARD I THINK
THAT.
.
THE TRICK THOUGH WITH TARGETING
REVERSALS IN IS THAT.
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY JUST TARGETED
THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY THINK ABOUT
THE UNIVERSAL GOAL.
AND WE THINK ABOUT INEQUALITY WE
OFTEN FOCUS ON GETTING SAY WHAT
LATIN NEXT TUNES FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS TO WEAR WHITE
STUDENTS ARE. BUT IN MANY PLACES
WHAT WHAT WHITE STUDENTS HAVE
SHOULD BE THE GOAL. RIGHT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET EVERYONE TO
UNIVERSAL GOAL.
AND SO IT'S THERE REALLY IS THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN TARGETING.
WHICH MIGHT IN ON SOME PLEASE
LOOK LIKE AN AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
STRATEGY AND ACTUALLY GETTING
EVERYONE TO THE UNIVERSAL GOAL
WHICH MEANS CREATING SUPPORTS.
IN THE LATTER'S IN THE IN THE
CAPACITIES TO DO THAT.
SO IF I THINK I THINK YOU'RE
THERE SO YOU REALLY ARE SHIFTING
A PARADIGM SO TO SPEAK SO THAT'S
RIGHT SIDE BRING IN THAT
DARTBOARD TO THE DARK. IN SOME
CASES IT CAN MODOC PLAYOFFS ON
US.
OKAY YEAH I THINK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
I WILL MOVE ON NOW WITH GRAHAM
DOBSON.
WITH THAT GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
COMMISSIONERS ON GRAHAM PHELPS
AND I WORK AT THEY SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICE OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION.
WHERE RECENTLY?
FORMED OFFICE WHERE WE WE
BROUGHT OF THE CONSOLIDATED ALL
OF THE FUNDING THAT WAS.
FOR THE VIEWS YOU TO FIVE YEAR
OLDS IN SAN FRANCISCO UNDER ONE
ROOF SO WHEREAS PREVIOUSLY WE
HAD THREE SEPARATE.
CITY DEPARTMENTS SORT OF
WORKING WITH THAT FUNDING IS
DOES FUNDING SOURCES REPORTED
UNDER ONE ROOF AS AN OFFICE OF
THE SEA.
AND.
RECENTLY WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A
NEW FUNDING MECHANISM FOR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE
CITY.
WOULD TREAT CALLED ARE ILL THE
LEADING SCHOLARSHIP SO I THINK
IT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE OF OF SOME
BUT YOU KNOW TO. TO GIVE A MODEL
OF WHAT WE KNOW WHAT WITHIN
TEMAS OF HOW TO EXPAND.
ACCESS AND ALSO.
ESPECIALLY TO HIGH QUALITY
ENVIRONMENTS
SO I JUST SOME CONTEXT
I YOU KNOW I THINK AS A MODEL
SAN FRANCISCO'S A LITTLE IS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE WHERE PRETTY
UNIQUE AT PLACES WHERE BOTH YOU
KNOW WHERE CITY AND THE COUNTY
AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND WE DO HAVE.
.
I SOME SIGNIFICANT AT A LOCAL
INVESTMENTS IN ONLY TEN
EDUCATION THROUGH SOME.
SOME SET ASIDES AND.
AND TAX.
DEL SET ASIDES THAT COME TO E.
C. E. SPECIFICALLY SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF LOCAL INVESTMENTS THAT WE
CAN USE WHICH I ISN'T ALWAYS THE
CASE IN AND OTHER COUNTIES.
I'M NOT GONNA GO THROUGH ALL OF
THIS I THINK YOU ALL KNOW WHERE
A HIGH COST COUNTY RENTS ARE
RIDICULOUS.
AND AND IT'S IT'S REALLY HARD
TO DO BUSINESS THERE AND TO LIVE
THERE.
BUT WE DO HAVE A ABOUT FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN.
UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE AS PART
OF A POPULATION.
THEY TOOK IT A LITTLE BIT OF A
BREAK DOWN OF THAT PICKED THE
INCOME OF THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
WITHIN THOSE FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
CHILDREN. THE YELLOW IS THAT OUR
CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW WE BOTH INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND PRESCHOOL AGE WHO
UNDER THE STATE A SUBSIDY
ELIGIBILITY OF EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE SMI YES I MY
DOESN'T REALLY WORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO BECAUSE IT'S A STATE
MEDIAN INCOME AND THAT'S DOESN'T
REALLY. WORK WITH US SO WE KNOW
WHAT WE'VE WE'VE BEEN WORKING OR
IN OUR OFFICE LOT JUST LOOKING
AT THE SUBSIDIES STATE
SUBSIDIZED.
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES BUT ALSO.
WE WHAT WE CALL LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME FAMILIES WHO ARE BETWEEN
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE SMI
AND A HUNDRED AND TEN PERCENT OF
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME WHICH IS
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE AIR MY AS
OPPOSED TO THE SMI.
IT IS ASKING QUICK QUESTION
THERE I'M SORRY MY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MISS I KNOW HE WOULD BE
THE PERHAPS HILL TOLD ME THAT HE
SAYS ALLOW YOU TO GO BACK TO SAN
FRANCISCO. BUT THEY SAY THE JOKE
THAT THE LAST PERSON WITH A
FAMILY CLOSE THE DOOR ON THE WAY
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE
SHOWING HERE IS THAT. YOU'RE
SEEING THAT RIGHT HERE FOR ZERO
TO TWO.
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM THREE TO
FIVE RIGHT.
HERE ARE YOUR SAYING THAT THAT
THAT THE FAMILY THE NEWER
FAMILIES.
OUR EAT THE INCOME IS.
HIGHER CORRECT SO DIRECT.
SO AND THEN THE GREEN HERE AS
ABOVE FAMILIES WITH INCOME ABOVE
A HUNDRED TEN PERCENT OF YET AM
I.
SO CURRENTLY THAT THE FACT THAT
THE TARGET AUTAUGA POPULATION
WITHIN OUR WITH OUR SYSTEM THAT
WE FUNDING LOCALLY JUST BECAUSE
EVEN WITH OUR.
MONEY THAT COME THAT WE HAVE
LOCALLY FATS FLEXIBLE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH TO SERVE EVERY
SINGLE UNIT YOU KNOW UNIVERSAL.
IN FROM TOTAL OF ZERO TO FIVE
PRESCHOOL ACCESS WE DON'T HAVE
THAT SO AGAIN ARE TARGETED OUR
TARGET IS UP TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
PERCENT OF AT MY WITHIN OUR
FUNDING SYSTEM.
SO I GUESS OUR OUR OVER ACHIEVED
GOALS REALLY OUGHT TO INCREASE
FUNDING TO THE PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE TO TO REALLY COVER THE
CUT THE ACTUAL COST OF PROVIDING
HIGH QUALITY CARE WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
RECEIVING SOME YOU KNOW. FUNDING
FROM THE STATE AND FROM THE FADS
THAT THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES A
DALY REIMBURSEMENTS JUST DON'T
GO ANYWHERE NEAR A MILLION THE
COST OF ACTUALLY PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY OF CARE. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE REALLY LOOKING
FOR IS LOOKING FOR CONTINUITY OF
CARE THAT ONCE A CHILD'S AND
DOES THE SYSTEM AT ANY AGE FROM
ZERO TO FIVE. THAT WE WILL
GUARANTEE FUNDING FOR THAT
FAMILY TO RECEIVE SERVICES FROM
WHENEVER THE END OF THE SYSTEM
UP TO WHEN THEY HAD TO
KINDERGARTEN. YOU KNOW HAS BEEN
SO MUCH CHAIRMAN IN AND OUT OF
SIGHT OF ELIGIBILITY AND AND
DIFFERENT SUBSIDY FUNDING
SOURCES FOR FAMILIES AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE'VE SEEN
THAT FAMILIES LOSE A. LEASE
SUBSIDIES A LOSE ACCESS AND THEN
TO THE GAP AND THEN THE CHILD
YOU KNOW LOSES THEIR THEIR
SERVICES AND THEN WE HAVE TO
START THE FAMILY STARTS OVER
AGAIN AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY. MINIMIZE THAT COMPLETELY
BY SEN ONCE YOU'RE NOT SYSTEM
ONCE YOU'RE ELIGIBLE YOU GET
EMAIL YOU GET YOU KNOW A FUNDING
WE WILL GUARANTEE THAT WE WILL
FOLLOW YOU ALL THE WAY UP TO CAN
THE GARDEN. WE DO HAVE TARGET
POPULATIONS PRIORITY POPULATIONS
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THAT'S
BE. LIKE REALLY US FOCUSING ON.
IT LOW INCOME AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO FAMILIES ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS HOMELESS
FAMILIES OF. CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND
CHILLING WITH SPECIAL NEEDS WE
DO YOU KNOW AFRICAN AMERICAN
LATINO FAMILIES. WE ARE
SPECIFICALLY CALLING UP BECAUSE
WE SEE A LOT OF DISC YOU KNOW
ONE OF THOSE DISCREPANCIES IN
THE KINDERGARTEN READINESS.
I IN SAN FRANCISCO DESPITE ALL
OF OUR.
INVESTMENTS ON AND WORK TOWARDS
A MINIMIZING THAT WE ARE SEEING
THESE DIFFERENCES IN CAN BEGUN
READING OF SCORES AND SO WE
REALLY WANT IT WITH LATINO OR
NOT.
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILIES AS
OPPOSED TO ASIAN AND WHITE
FAMILY SO THATS WHY. YOU KNOW
THERE IS A PRIORITY FOR.
FOR SERVICES AND IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES WITHIN CERTAIN
DEMOGRAPHICS.
WE ONE.
TERM TO FULLY UTILIZE OF STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
COMING TO LOOK TO MY COUNTY. WE
DON'T WANT TO LEAVE DOLLARS ON
THE TABLE YOU WILL USE ALL OF
THE STATE MONEY THAT YOU GET ALL
OF THE FEDERAL MONEY. THAT WE
GET BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OUR
LOCAL GOES AWAY MORE FLEXIBLE
AND WE CAN DO A LOT MORE WITH
NOTS REVIEWS WE WILL LEVERAGE
THOUGH STATE AND FEDERAL
DOLLARS.
AND LIKE I SAID BEFORE WE REALLY
WANT TO TRY TO ASSIST MORE
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES BECAUSE
THAT THE STATE ELIGIBILITY OR
FEDERAL LEVELS WILL HE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY WORK FOR. FOR THE
REALITY OF SOME OF OUR FAMILIES
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO I WILL GO THROUGH ALL OF THIS
I JUST WHEN YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A CITY WIDE PLANNED FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION THAT
WAS OF THERE WAS A HUGE
COMMUNITY PROCESS I THINK A
LAWSUIT OVER YEAR LOTS OF.
FEEDBACK SESSIONS LOTS OF
FORUMS.
AND THAT'S A VISION FOR WHERE
WE'RE GOING AS A CITY WE WE HAVE
A DOCUMENT THAT THAT THAT'S OUR
GUIDING STAR.
I THINK IT'S THE ONE THING I
DID WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FROM THIS
IS THAT REALLY THE IDEA OF GOING
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY DOING
LOTS OF INPUT SESSIONS MEETING
BETH PROVIDER ASSOCIATIONS WITH
A. THAT LOCAL PLANNING COUNCIL
FIRST FIVE ARE.
YOU KNOW THE FAMILY CHILDCARE
ASSOCIATION MEMBERS WE WENT OUT
THE APPARENT VOICES REAL LOT OF
WITH A LOT OF FEEDBACK A LOT OF
COMMUNITY INPUT BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR EARLY LEARNING
SCHOLARSHIP.
WE ARE FUNDING SYSTEM AND THAT
WAS LAUNCHED JUST IN JULY LAST
YEAR SO WE'RE STILL IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION SO IT'S.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN INTERESTING.
.
SO THIS AGAIN IS ARE SOME OF THE
CITYWIDE PLAN OUR STRATEGIC
FRAMEWORK THAT GUIDES ALL WORK
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE TOP
AROUND BEST A FIVE APPROACH OUR.
EQUITY IN DIVERSE CITY QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
WORK FORCE AND THE FINANCING
MODELS AND THE FINANCING MODEL
SPECIFICALLY HOURS ARE ONLY
GOING SCHOLARSHIP. PROVIDING
FEDERAL RATES TO PROVIDERS AND
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR FAMILIES.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'LL BE
FOCUSING ON TODAY.
I THINK WE ARE TOLD ABOUT THIS
AGAIN THIS IS ONE OF OUR OWN
OVER ARCHING GOALS AS WE DON'T
WANT DISQUALIFYING CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE GOING OVER THE INCOME LEVEL
FOR. FOR ELIGIBILITY TO BE A
BARRIER TO TO COME TO CONTINUITY
OF CARE SO ONE OF OUR REAL.
.
OVERARCHING SORT OF FRAMEWORK IS
URINE UP TALK IN THE GARDEN AND
YOU NO MATTER WHAT.
SO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH IS HIGH
QUALITY E. C. E. COST IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
WELL IT MIGHT NOT THIS IS THIS
IS SORT OF OUR.
.
THE OVERARCHING KIND OF IDEA
BEHIND WHAT ARE ONLY LETTING
SCHOLARSHIP BASS.
SO WOULD HAVE CENTER RATES AND
WE HAVE FAMILY CHILDCARE RIGHTS
AND WE HAD A COMPREHENSIVE
FISCAL ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE BY
A TEAM IN NATIONAL TEAM THAT
CAME OUT TO SAN FRANCISCO. THEY
MET WITH CENTER DIRECTORS
TEACHERS FAMILIES.
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS TO
TO REALLY LOOK AT BUT YOU KNOW
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WENT INTO
OF WHAT IT COSTS TO PROVIDE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
SERVICES THAT WAS UP LIKE A I
THINK A NINE MONTH PROCESS WHERE
WE DID THIS REALLY INTENSIVE
STE.
CFA AM IT'S A TOUCHY AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE WITH ITS VERY
DETAIL THE FLIGHT TWO HUNDRED
PAGES.
AND WHAT WE CAME UP WITH WITH
THESE BENCHMARK RATES FOR EACH
SAT FOR EACH AGE GROUP WITHIN
SANTA AND FCC.
SO FOR INFANTS
OUR ANNUAL RATE WOULD BE A HIGH
QUALITY AND ARE A BENCHMARK IS
T. IF THREE OF THE. STATE Q. R.
S.
SO IS A YOU KNOW TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO BE ANOTHER LEADING
SCHOLARSHIP.
YOU KNOW PROVIDE OF SANTA A
FAMILY CHILDCARE.
EDUCATOR IN OUR IN OUR NETWORK
LIVES A GUARANTEE THAT YOU AYE
THAT ALREADY AT TI A THREE OF
THE CURE I S. OR. FOR FAMILY
CHILDCARE BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT DICK
CURIOUS CERTAINLY IS NOT AS
ACCESSIBLE AND.
IT MAY REQUIRE MORE TIME THERE
WAS A COMMIT A COMMITTED A
COMMITMENT TO MOVE TOWARDS TO
YOU THREE OF THE CURIOUS FOR THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE EDUCATION IS.
SO WHERE USING TEAR THREE IS A
BASELINE SO WHAT WOULD IT COST
TO PROVIDE TIER THREE QUALITY E.
C. E. IN BOTH CENTERS AND FROM
WHICH OUT THERE. AND FOR CENTERS
AT WIRED FOR INFINITE WAS TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS A YEAR.
FOR A TABLA IT'S TWENTY THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS A YEAR AND FOR PRESCHOOL
IT WAS SEVENTEEN THOUSAND AND
SIXTY NINE DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND WE'RE ALREADY GETTING
FEEDBACK FROM OUR.
NETWORK THAT DUTCH NEWMAN HAAS.
THAT THOSE RIGHTS ARE NOT ENOUGH
AND STILL DON'T MATCH THE COST
OF ACTUALLY PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY CARE IN A COUNTY LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO.
SO FOR SOME OF OUR.
CHILDREN IN THE CITY THAT DON'T
A QUALIFY FOR ANY OF ITS FEDERAL
STATE SUBSIDIES WE WILL PROVIDE
VOUCHERS LOCALLY FUNDED VOUCHERS
THAT WOULD PAY THAT FULL RIGHT
OF THOSE AMOUNTS UP TO CHEER
THAT TIA THREE BASE RIGHT.
FOR FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE
RECEIVING SUBSIDIES FROM IF
TITLE FIVE OR HEAD START OR ST
VOUCHERS THE CAL EXPENDITURES WE
WILL PAY THE GAP BETWEEN WHAT
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS FROM
THE STATE'S. UP TO THAT TF THREE
LOCAL RIGHT
AND THAT'S ABOUT GAP FUNDING TO
BRING EVERYBODY UP TO THAT THAT
SAME AMOUNT PER CHILD.
FOR HEAD START AFTER THE BRAID
THEM UNPLANNED FUNDING WITH HEAD
START AND TITLE FIVE AGAIN WILL
BRIDGE THAT GAP SO THEY CAN
BRING IT UP TO THE. THE SAN
FRANCISCO RIGHT
SO YOU KNOW I ALSO WE HAVE
UNIVERSAL PFA FOUGHT THAT IS NOT
INCOME.
BASED AND WE STILL HAVE TUITION
CREDIT FOR FAMILIES REGARDLESS
OF INCOME FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS WHO
ELIGIBLE FOR PRESCHOOL FOR ALL.
SO THAT'S KIND OF ARE WE ARE
GOAL EVENTUALLY IS TO GET TWO
TIERED REIMBURSEMENTS FOR BOTH
TF FOR ANTI A FIVE. A IN THE
CURIOUS WE'RE NOT THERE YET
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
CURRENTLY.
SO THIS IS A LOT OF THOSE LITTLE
THINGS THAT I DIDN'T PUT IN.
BUT.
YEAH. SO I AGAIN I THINK THIS IS
FOR YOUHAVE THIS IN YOUR
HANDOUTS IT SHOWS YOU THE RIGHTS
ONE THING I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT HERE THIS OF CENTER.
AGAIN ON OUR WEBSITE.
IN OUR OPERATING GUIDELINES YOU
CAN FIND ALL THE RIGHTS BUT
FOUND ITSELF AND CENTERS BUT WE
DO PAY A FIVE PERCENT
DIFFERENTIAL EVEN ON THE FULL
DAY FULL YEAR RIGHTS FOR THOSE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT. PROVIDE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FROM INFANT
THROUGH.
FIVE YEAR OLDS SO AGAIN
INCENTIVES TO.
TO SERVE THE FULL RANGE OF
INFANTS TODDLERS AND
PRESCHOOLERS BECAUSE.
INFANTS AND TODDLERS OF THE
BIGGEST UNMET NEED FOR.
SERVICES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
AGAIN I MENTIONED THAT WE REALLY
WANTED TO UTILIZE STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING AS PART OF A
SCREENING FALL LOCALLY FUNDED
SERVICES YOU WANT IT YOU KNOW WE
LOOK TO SEE IF A FAMILY IS
ELIGIBLE FOR ANY. STATE OR
FEDERAL FUNDING BEFORE THEY'RE
FULLY REIMBURSED IT OUT OF THE
LIVING SCHOLARSHIP RIGHTS WE
WANT SIVA FAMILY COMES AND. TO
OUR RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
AGENCIES.
AVAILABLE FOR HEAD START OF
ELIGIBLE FOR TITLE FIVE COULD BE
ON A CAL EXPENDITURE IF NOT I'LL
BE ELIGIBLE FOROAKLAND
SCHOLARSHIP AND WILL PAY THE
FULL WEIGHT. AS OPPOSED TO JUST
THE GAP BETWEEN THE.
VERY.
AT THE STATE OR FEDERAL.
FUNDING.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO HAVE A PILOT
WE ARE A PILOT COUNTY SO WE'RE
VERY LUCKY WE HAVE.
TWENTY FOUR MONTH ELIGIBILITY
AND.
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE SMI
IS AN ENTRANCE OF INCOME SO THAT
BY HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE AND.
YOU KNOW EARLY IN OUR STATE
CONTRACTS.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW I'VE GONE
THROUGH MOST OF WHAT WAS BEFORE
AND WHAT WAS WHAT WHAT WE HAVE
WITH OUR EARLIER IN SCHOLARSHIPS
AS FAR AS YOU KNOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATES AND CONTINUITY OF CARE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
THE INCOME FOR FAMILIES THAT AT
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF YOUR SMI
AT SIXTY THREE THOUSAND FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE IS THE CLIFF.
WITH ARE A HUNDRED AND TEN
PERCENT OF THE I AM I IT'S A
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE SO IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
EARNINGS BUT A FAMILY COULD
MAKE.
AND STILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR SOME
FORM OF.
SUBSIDY TO IT TOOK FOR IT ON
THE CARE AND EDUCATION AND AGAIN
QUALITY IS APPLIES TO ALL OF
OUR.
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY AND QUALITY
INSURANCES FOR ALL OF THE.
INCENTIVES AND AS HE SEES THAT
ARE IN OUR.
NETWORK.
SO SO QUALITY HAS IT YOU KNOW
WHAT HAVE WE SEEN ANY IMPACT IN
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON AS FAR AS
YOU KNOW WHERE WE HAVE THIS.
REQUIREMENT TO TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CURIOUS TO BE
PART OF OUR SYSTEM.
AND THIS IS FROM FIRST FIVE SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE ORANGE AS TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN WHETHER IT
THIS IS BOTH CENTERS AND FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS.
A COMBINED THE AND THEN THE
GREEN.
IS A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE NO.
NONE OF OUR AGENCIES THAT ARE
WITHIN OUR NETWORK UNTIL ONE.
WE HAVE VERY FEW INTO YOUR
THREE.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IN T. A FOREIGN TO
FIVE.
SO WE HAVE YOU KNOW I WE HOPE
AND WE WE.
WE MAKE SOME ASSUMPTIONS BUT WE
THINK THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING AND QUALITY.
DOTA COACHING.
ALL THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE FOR A PART OF OUR
NETWORK.
HAVE ACCESS TO HAVE MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT.
YOU KNOW IMPROVEMENTS IN AN
HOUR QUALITY SCORES AND FAMILY
CHILDCARE BROUGH.
EDUCATORS WE HAVE TO FAMILY
CHILDCARE QUALITY NETWORKS THAT
A HOUSE ABOUT YOU RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCIES AGAIN WE WE
FUND THAT'S WHERE OUR OFFICE AND
THEY PROVIDE THE COACHING T. A
INDIRECT. INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES THAT ARE
IN THOSE NETWORK.
AND THE FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES
AND UPLAND ABOUT YEAH LET'S
PROGRAM ARE REQUIRED TO BE IN
THE QUEUE AND A CALL THE NETWORK
TO GET THOSE SERVICES.
LESSONS LEARNT REIMBURSEMENT
RATES SHOULD MEET THE COST OF
ACTUAL COST TO PROVIDE IN THE
CARE INSTEAD OF FIFTY PERCENT.
OR LESS OUR CONTINUITY OF CARE
IS VITAL.
STARTING EARLY IS VITAL AND ONE
TALKS ABOUT YOU KNOW CONSIDER
PKB ON START AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE IT'S REALLY VITAL TO
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT FOR ZERO OF
THREE YEAR OLDS AS WELL AS THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS.
CHILDCARE CLIFFS AND WE NEED TO
BE SMOOTHED YOU KNOW THOSE EDGES
JUST NEED TO BE SMOOTH SO TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES.
YOU KNOW THE EXISTING SUBSIDY
SYSTEM OF OF DIFFERENT AGES YOU
KNOW REQUIREMENTS FOR THE REFUND
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
THE VOUCHERS AND A. BIT THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT AGE CATEGORIES
FOR INFANTS TODDLERS AND
PRESCHOOLERS JUST LIKE IT CAN
GET REALLY COMPLICATED WAY
TRYING TO WORK WITH IN A
FRAGMENTED SYSTEM.
SO YOU KNOW UP AND MIXED
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS VITAL WE
FOUND THAT WE WORK WITH YOU KNOW
BOTH OF A FAMILY CHILDCARE
EDUCATORS AND A SIX COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND A SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
.
AND.
DATA IS BEING YOU KNOW WE REALLY
NEED A CAR A CONSOLIDATED DATA
TO BE ABLE TO DO THE WORK THAT
WE DO IN SAM'S US GOING THAT'S
AN ONGOING STRUGGLE FOR US IN
THE WORKING ON THAT.
IT'S CHALLENGING THAT'S OF
THAT'S THEY GO THAT'S A LESSON
LEARNED IT'S VERY CHALLENGING.
.
BRIGHT SPOTS WE'VE IMPROVED THE
LEVERAGING OF STATE AND FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
BECAUSE WHERE GIVEN AN INCENTIVE
AFFECT FOR FOR PROGRAMS TO IN
THOSE DOLLARS NOW AND TAKE THOSE
VIRUSES. AND USE TITLE FIVE
DOLLARS BECAUSE WE PAY THE
DIFFERENCE INSTEAD OF GETTING.
EL EVERY EMBRACE RAY THAT
DOESN'T YOU BECAUSE OF CARE TO
COUNT YOUR COUNSELING IN THE RED
WAY SAY WE'LL PAY YOU MORE ON
TOP OF THAT TIED TO TO SERVE
THOSE CHILDREN.
CONTINUITY OF CARE.
AND WE WERE PART OF OUR SYSTEM
IS E. SIGNATURE LOOKING TO ELECT
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE SYSTEM
ACROSS THE BOARD TO CAPTURE
ABOUT DATA REALLY.
.
SIMPLY
WE HAVE HAD SOME BRIGHT SPOTS
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUR
SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY HOMELESS
CHILDREN AND FOR INFANTS
TODDLERS AND WE HAVE A BALLOT
MEASURE GOING ON IN JUNE TO
RAISE ANOTHER HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR ELF
SYSTEM.
WHICH WOULD BE AMAZING IF THAT
PASSES.
IT'S BEEN A MASS OF.
SYSTEM CHANGE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND NOT HAS NOT BEEN WITHOUT
ITS.
ROCKY ROADS DISPERSED YEAR I
THINK WE FOUND THAT WE MOVED
FROM A FUNDING PER SITE MODEL
THAT WE HAD DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS DIFFERENT EIGHT AREAS
OF THE FIELD. SOMETHING FOR A
COMPENSATION SOMETHING FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS SOMETHING
FOR.
QUALITY AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
WE'VE AMALGAMATED ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS INTO
ONE EARLY LEARNING SCHOLARSHIP
WHICH IS A CHILD BASED.
YOU KNOW FEE FOR SERVICE BASED
ON CHILDREN ENROLLMENT SO THAT
WAS A HUGE SYSTEM SHIFT AND.
CHANGE IS DIFFICULT AND THAT
PROGRAMS THAT WERE CUT WE WILL
BE IN FUNDED BY THE CITY WHEN WE
BROUGHT IN THIS NEW SYSTEM
DEFINITELY THERE WAS SOME.
CHALLENGES TO DOUBT ABOUT
CHANGING HOW WE WORK FUND IN
THE.
SERVICES.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A VERY LONG
TIMELINE FOR PLANNING AND.
IMPLEMENTATION SO THAT WAS WE
HAD A QUICK TURNAROUNDS ARE ALL
HAPPENED WAY TOO QUICKLY.
.
AND YOU KNOW THIS IDEA YOU KNOW
I THINK ARE.
ARMED SERVICES BY ABOUT
ENROLLMENT BEGETTING CHILDREN IN
SPACE EMPTY SPACES IN PROGRAMS
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WE WERE
ALREADY BUILDING ON OF OUR
SYSTEM THAT WASN'T AS EFFICIENT
AS WE SHOULD HAVE. BEEN OUR OUR.
ELIGIBILITY LIST WE HAD WE
STILL HAVE A CENTRALIZED
ELIGIBILITY LIST IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAD WE KEPT THAT ON
AFTER THE STATE DEFUNDED THOSE
AND SO OUR SYSTEM DOES WASN'T
READY FOR THIS NEW CHANGE A IN
THIS AND ASSIST THEM IN THIS
SPAWNING. A SYSTEM AND SO WE HAD
SOME YOU KNOW WE HAD SOME.
.
THE FIRST FEW MONTHS IT WAS WE
WERE GETTING CHILDREN THOSE
EMPTY SPACES AS QUICKLY AS WE
SHOULD HAVE AND SO THAT WAS A
THAT WAS A CHALLENGE.
AND AGAIN THE DATA SYSTEMS I
THINK OUR.
I'VE BEEN A CHALLENGING SO WORK
ON DATA SYSTEMS ARE WORKING ON
YOU ELIGIBILITY LIST.
SO THAT WAS QUICK SORRY I KNEW
THAT WE WERE KIND OF RUNNING OUT
OF TIME BUT THANK YOU.
I'LL START OFF WITH WITH A FEW
QUESTIONS.
I AM THE MIKE HERE SO.
I I KINDA BLAND IS THAT
COMMISSION HAD AND.
MY BUDGET AT SO I OVERSEE THAT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR EASY.
AND.
LOOKING AT THAT THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN THE RATE
STRUCTURE AND BASIC YOUR CARE
FAMILIES THAT ARE NOW IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE INCREASED.
.
SLOTS LAST FEW YEARS AS WELL AS.
MARGINALLY NOT LARGELY BUT WE'VE
INCREASED RATES.
AT LAST FEARS AS WELL SO HOW'S
THAT SORTING OUT IN TRYING TO TO
FIND FAMILIES THAT THAT MATCHED
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT WERE.
PUTTING OUT FROM CD FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. OUT I MEAN
I'D THAT'S A INTEGRAL PART OF
OUR SYSTEM I MEAN THAT BIG THIS
I THINK I HOPE THE MAJORITY OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE WORK WITH
THE CENTERS THAT WE WORK WITH AN
AYE EE LSI EARLY ON IN
SCHOLARSHIP. OUR TITLE FIVE
PROGRAM I GET THAT BUT BUT ARE
YOU HAVING TROUBLE FINDING
FAMILIES WHAT I'M SAYING ARE ARE
ARE ARE UTILIZING ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE GIVING YOU
FROM THE STATE SONS DISTRICT
SOME COMMUTER THING. RAMMING A
TOUGH TIME WHEN YOU'RE NOT BUT
WE DOING BETTER. AND I THINK
PART TWO OF THE THINGS I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW WE SO WE WERE AS A
PILOT COUNTY WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT.
EARNINGS OF OUR CONTRACTS VERY
VERY CLOSELY OVER THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS AND WE'VE SEEN THIS
YEAR THAT WE'RE DOING BETTER
THAN WE DID LAST YEAR. TO THE
THINGS I THINK ONE THE LS THIS
THIS REIMBURSEMENT RATE THIS
INCENTIVE TO EARN THE CONTRACT
BECAUSE IT'S YOU'RE NOT GETTING.
THEM THE STATE RIGHT.
IS AN INCENTIVE TO TO USE
THOUGH TO ENROLL MORE CHILDREN
INSTEAD OF TAKING A LOT OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE MIXED INCOME NOW
HAVE FAMILIES THAT PAY FEES AS
WELL AND SO REDUCING THEM NUMBER
OF PHOEBE OUR FAMILY FEE.
FAMILIES BUT TAKEN MORE A TITLE
FIVE MORE VOUCHER CHILDREN FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE WE PAY IN ON TOP
OF THAT SO IT'S NOT BECAUSE THAT
THAT REIMBURSE ALL RIGHT UP FROM
THE STATE IS. IS ENCOURAGING
THEM TO DO IT BUT BECAUSE WAY
HELPING SUPPORT THEM AND MEETING
LIKE THE COST OF PROVIDING CARE
AND THEN THE OTHER THING THAT I
THINK HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE OF
SOME OF THE STATE.
POLICIES THAT HAVE CHANGED
RECENTLY STATEWIDE WE HAVE
TWELVE MONTH ELIGIBILITY ONCE
YOU AND YOUR GOOD FOR TWELVE
MONTHS UNLESS THERE'S BEEN A
CHANGE YOU KNOW TO THAT OF THE
INCOME LEVEL AND FOR IN THE IN
SOME CISCO WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
MONTH ELIGIBILITY THE SAME AS
THE PILOT COUNTIES. AND SO I
THINK THAT AGAIN THAT THAT.
FOCUS ON ELIGIBILITY AND AND
FAMILY ALL YOUR FAMILY
ELIGIBILITY IN TAKING THAT AWAY
A LITTLE BIT IT'S BEEN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOOD FOR A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME. HAS MEANT BACK AGAIN
THAT THERE'S MORE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROGRAMS TO
USE THOSE.
THAT THAT THE STATE FUNDING
OKAY
WHILE YOU'RE HERE YOU CARE
PRACTITIONER OF WE HAD OUR LAST
HEARING.
DOWN IN THE DESERT AND WE HEARD
FROM.
THE AREA DOWN THERE THE
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL DISTRICT
TALKING ABOUT.
THE.
.
THAT T. K. OPPORTUNITIES AND
STATE PRESCHOOL AND HOW DOES HOW
TO SAN FRANCISCO.
CAN MANAGE THAT WITH THE IF YOU
HAVE A. KID THAT'S BORN.
IN MARCH AND SO THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR TEA QUE CAN BUT
THEY COULD BE ELIGIBLE MADE YEAR
WHAT WHAT ARE YOU DOING THERE
ARE YOU TO ENROLL THEM PART YEAR
AND AND HOW HAS THAT WORKED.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S UP TO THAT I
MEAN THAT'S A FAMILY CHOICE IT'S
LIKE WE WE WILL ENROLL A CHILD
FOR AS LONG AS THEY NEED TO BE
BEFORE THEY GO INTO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO MATT AND I DO YOU
ENROLL THEM IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND. AND THEN
MID YEAR TRANSITION OR HOW DO
YOU DO THAT WE DON'T DO WE WE
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC.
POLICY AROUND.
STATE PRESCHOOL ON T. QUE YOU
KNOW AGAIN I THINK THAT HAPPENS
I THINK SOMETIMES A FAMILY MIGHT
START IT IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND THEN REALIZE THAT
THERE'S A T. K. PROGRAM WITH
SPACES DOWN THE ROAD. AND THEY
DO HAVE TO PAY A FEE THAT FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE IT'S A
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO I CAN I THINK
THAT'S A LOT OF PARENTAL CHOICE
WE DON'T. WE WE DON'T GIVE ANY
INSTRUCTIONS TO OUR PROGRAMS OUT
WHETHER. WHAT AGES I STRESSED
ABOUT IT BUT HAVE YOU FIGURED
OUT HOW TO BREED THAT TO TO HELP
THE FAMILIES IS?
METAL FINANCES NOW SHORT ANSWER
IS NO AREA SOMEONE MEMBER I HAVE
A FOUR AND A HALF YEAR OLD WHO'S
TWENTY FIVE SEPTEMBER SEVENTH
AND I CAN WALK YOU THROUGH. WHAT
AT INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING STRESSFUL PROCESSES
YET WE DON'T I DON'T KNOW I
MENTIONED THAT ARE LESS YEAH?
I COMMISSIONER*.
SO YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU
BOOTH TO QUALITY STANDARDS THAT
VARY BY SETTING AND THEN NOW
IT'S THE SAME HIGH QUALITY
STANDARDS FOR ALL OF HER
SETTINGS WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED
ABOUT THE WORK FORCE THERE YOU
MENTIONED COMPENSATION YOU
MENTIONED CHO CHANG COME. WELL.
COMPENSATION IS PROBABLY THAT
THE BIGGEST.
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS
OF STORE EVERY.
MEETING THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR
GRANTEES THAT TO MEAN THAT WE
TRY TO THE COMMUNITY. THAT THE
CAUSE OF THE WORK FORCE CRISIS
SOMETIME FRANCISCO WE HAVE
CLASSROOMS THAT AREN'T OPEN
BECAUSE.
PROGRAMS CONFINED TEACHERS TO
WORK IN THOSE CLASSROOMS.
ONE OF THE FOR THE A ONE OF THE.
I THINK.
SO THE CAN SO COMPENSATION IS
INCORPORATED YOU KNOW THE WAGES
WERE INCORPORATED AS PART OF THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS AS TO WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE. PEOPLE WE ALSO
INSTEAD OF TIME TO WAGE SPECIFIC
INITIATIVE WHICH WE USED TO HAVE
WE SAW WITH THE HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT RATE PER CHILD WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS ABSOLVED IN
THIS IN THIS NEW SCHOLARSHIP.
WHAT WE WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
AGAIN WE'RE JUST HEARING THAT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THAT THAT? LOW WAGES GONE
OUTWILL HAVE BEEN MINIMAL WE'RE
LOOKING AT MINIMUM COMPENSATION
ELEMENTS THAT WOULD BRING UP.
THE MINIMUM WAGE WITH CITY
FUNDED PROGRAMS OF ABOVE THE
MINIMUM WAGE IF YOU KNOW UP TO A
SIXTEEN OVER SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR. SO EVERYTHING WHAT YOU
KNOW IT'S WE JUST CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH WHAT WHAT THAT. EDUCATORS
NEED TO MAKE IT SHOULD BE
MAKING.
SO.
IN THIS ISSUE BALLOT MEASURE
THAT'S COMMAND JUNE IF IT PASSES
A LOT OF THE LANGUAGES AROUND
COMPENSATION FOR.
THE EDUCATORS OF THE POT OF
IDEALISTS.
SO INCREASE THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES TO TO TO SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THAT BUT WE DO HAVE A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PIECE
THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE DO SO
IT'S VERY SPECIFIC WE HAVE A
WHOLE QUALITY PEOPLE.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
SORT OF.
WORK THAT'S PART OF OUR OFFICE
SPENDS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW SYSTEM EVERYWHERE
PREFERS FIVE WE WORK WITH A HIGH
RIGHT TO INSTITUTIONS WE WORK
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AROUND.
ACCESS TO OPT FOR A EDUCATORS
THE TEACHERS IN THE FAMILY CHALK
ALLIGATORS.
TWO TRAININGS IN WORKSHOPS AND
ONGOING EDUCATION.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER
UNLEASHES.
WE FINISHED.
EVER.
.
GRAHAM SINCE THIS IS THE
FINANCING AND A CONVERSATION I I
DON'T KNOW DID YOU DESCRIBE I
MEAN. THESE LOCAL DOLLARS CAME
OUT OF A PREVIOUS BALLOT
INITIATIVE WE DID YES BUT YEAH
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAD.
A PROPERTY TAX SET ASIDE FOR
OUR CHILDREN'S FUND.
AND THEN WHICH A PORTION OF THAT
GOES TO ZERO TO FIVE YEAR OLD SO
THAT USED TO BE HAS HAD A
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES AND THAT THE FUNDING
THAT'S ALLOCATED TO ZERO TO FIVE
IS NOW. UNDER A HOUSE
THEN FIRST IN FIRST FIVE USED TO
RUN OUR PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
INITIATIVE AND THAT WAS FUNDED
BY A GENERAL FUND SET ASIDE
WHICH IS THE PUBLIC EDUCATION IN
RICHMOND FUND. AGAIN THAT
FUNDING WAS WAS ALLOCATED OVER
TO OUR OFFICE TO KEEP IT UNDER
ONE ROOF.
AND THEN WE HAVE SOME.
WE ALSO.
ADMITS TO SOME CAL WORK SOME
STATE DOLLARS THAT'S PART OF
THAT BUT THAT THE MAJORITY OF
OUR MONEY IS A. AND THAT WE HAVE
GENERAL FUND AS WELL SOME
GENERAL FUND SO IT'S TO SET
ASIDES GENERAL FUND AND SOME
STATE FUNDING WE HAVE A A BUDGET
AND OUR OFFICE OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION.
CAN YOU BREAK DOWN HOW MUCH OF
THAT WAS THESE SET ASIDES AND
LOCAL VERSES WHAT STATE.
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO ABOUT HOW.
BUT I GET THAT TO YOU A AND I
DIDN'T THAT'S WE IT WAS IN THE
OTHER PART.
POWER POINT I TOOK IT OUT
BECAUSE I THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE
INTERESTED.
COMMISSIONER MCMILLAN.
SO I THINK.
WHAT YOU REPRESENT IT IS
REMARKABLE ESPECIALLY WITH WHAT
CHIU BUT YOU GUYS HAVE DONE IN
SUCH A SHORT?
TIME FRAME I THINK IT'S AMAZING
AYE.
I HAVE A DREAM.
NOT MARTIN LUTHER KING'S MY OWN.
AND AYE ADD TEN. A LOT OF TOWN
HALLS ALLOTTED CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR.
SEATS AND SO FORTH.
AND I ALWAYS HEAR THEM SAY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES HAVE JOBS THAT THEY CAN
GO TO THAT THEIR KIDS CAN GET
INTO.
WHATEVER COLLEGE THEY WANT TO
BUT NOT ONCE.
HAVE I HEARD THEM SAY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES HAVE JOBS AND THEY CAN
GO TO THAT PAY THEM WELL AND
THAT THEIR CHILDREN AND THEIR
BABIES.
CAN HAVE QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION
AND CARE NOT ONCE.
I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE HERE.
MIGHT CHANGE.
THAT CONVERSATION.
I'M HOPING.
THAT THIS WOULD BE THE BEGINNING
OF CHANGE IN THAT CONVERSATION
AND MY DREAM IS THAT I CAN GO TO
A TOWN HALL.
AND HEAR WHAT I JUST SAID.
WE LET'S START AT THE BEGINNING
DON'T JUMP TO THE END.
START AT THE BEGINNING AND MAYBE
IF WE USE THAT TARGET
UNIVERSALISM THEM WE DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE THE. TEACHER BRING THE
CHILDREN WE CAN HELP THE
CHILDREN BRING THE TEACHER.
BUT I'M I'M SO IMPRESSED WITH
THIS AND I DEFINITELY WANNA
LEARN MORE ABOUT IT COME TO SEND
THIS GOD WILL FORGIVE YOU TO.
SHOW UP THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU COMMISSION ELECT.
WELL I COULD ASK A DOZEN
QUESTIONS BUT I WON'T.
THE ONE THAT I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN IS AS YOU SORT OF
RAISE THE RATE YOU TALKED ABOUT
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING TEACHERS
NOT HAVING CLASSROOM BUT I'M.
I'M WONDERING YOUR SEEING
ANYTHING IN TERMS OF SUPPLY.
A WORST ARE DO YOU STILL HAVE A
LOT OF FAMILIES THAT ARE USING.
.
UNLICENSED CARE OR OTHER
MECHANISMS SO A HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF FAMILIES AND SAN FRANCISCO
WITH VOUCHERS ARE ACTUALLY USING
LICENSED.
CARRIED AN UNLICENSED I MEAN
LIKE YOU KNOW FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS IN SIMON'S DISCO WE
YOU KNOW. WHAT THE NEXT PHASE I
YOU KNOW TO TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
FAMILY FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS AND
WHAT ARE WE DOING THERE THAT'S
THE NEXT PHASE AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY JUST PUT OUT?
SOME GRANT FUNDING YOU KNOW FOR
BILL TO APPLY FOR AND ONE OF
YOUR FOR INNOVATIVE IDEAS AND
ONE OF THEM IS AROUND WORKING
WITH FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS AND MAYBE LOOKING AT
TI HAD A HIGHER REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR THOSE. FAMILY FRIEND
AND NEIGHBOR PROVIDERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO DO SOME QUALITY
WORKSHOPS AND GET SOME TRAINING
AND BE PART OF THE SYSTEM AND
GET A HIGHER REIMBURSEMENT RIGHT
TO PROVIDE CARE FOR THE FOR THE
CHILDREN. SO THAT'S WHAT I NEXT
PHASE YOU KNOW THIS IS STILL
LIKE I SAID AS A FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND SO IT'S YOU
KNOW WE'RE STILL WELL LEARNING
AS WE GO.
BUT WE YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW WE
ALSO SEE THAT POTENTIALLY. I
THINK BACK TO.
COULD BE A PATHWAY FOR I THINK
THAT WAS MENTIONED BEFORE FOR
FOR A FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS TO MAYBE GOING TO
LICENSE CAFE GET IF THEY GET A
TASTE OF IT THROUGH SOME QUALITY
WORKSHOPS AND TRAININGS.
SPORT BUT.
YEAH I THINK YOU KNOW WE WE ARE
LUCKY WE DO HAVE BUT I THINK WE
HAVE A PRETTY GOOD SUPPLY.
WHERE WHAT WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
THIS YOU KNOW I MEAN ALL THE
NEED AND YOU KNOW INFANT
TODDLER?
KAREN AND EDUCATION IS IS A A
BIGGEST UNMET NEED AND HOUSE HAS
BEEN FOR DECADES AND SO WE
REALLY WANT TO INCENTIVIZE.
OF SAN DOESN'T FROM WHICH ALL
CARE OWNERS TO.
TO SERVE GOD ZERO THREE
POPULATION THAT'S OUR BIGGEST
STRUGGLE.
WHERE I PROBABLY NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF PRESCHOOLERS TO
ELIGIBLE BE IN MORE THAN NINETY
FIVE PERCENT FOR SUBSIDIES WHO
ARE? ARE ARE IN SOME FORM OF
SERVICES SO WE'RE DOING VERY
WELL RESULT THAT'S REMARKABLE.
PAY ARE ACTUALLY REPORTS A
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT.
TARGETED UNIVERSALIST.
YES LISTENER WITH THE.
GRAHAM THANK YOU ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
FIGURE OUT THE FUN STUFF IS A
COW AS A SOME FRANCISCO RESIDENT
MYSELF I ALWAYS LIKE TO
WHAT WE DO.
THERE AS WELL.
AND I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THE
COMPETITIVE NATURE OF THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT YOU'RE PUTTING
OUT ALL OF THEM ARE A CREATURE
TRIES ABOUT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS RIGHT FOR PRESCHOOLER
PER YEAR WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN THE STANDARD RAM.
RIGHT CURRENTLY ACROSS THE
STATE.
HOW COMPETITIVE IS THAT TO A
PRIVATE PAY PROGRAM?
NOT.
NO WORK LAUGHS
NO WE HAVE WE'VE WE'VE JUST
LOOKED AT SOME AYE WE HAVE WE
HAVE SOME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
SOME PRIVATE. WILL WRECKED MY
RECOGNIZING THAT EVEN ARE HIGHER
ELF CIVILIANS COST RATES ON
MEETING SOME OF THE PRIVATE PAY
RIGHTS.
IN THE CITY
AND SO WE DO HAVE SOME.
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT AGENCIES ARE
A PART OF ALL PRO A NETWORK WHO
ARE PRIMARILY SERVE A.
PRIVATE PAIN FAMILIES BUT WANT
TO SAVE SOME.
SOME SUBSIDY ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
WITHIN OUT WITHIN OUR FUNDING
SOURCE AND WILL LOOK THROUGH THE
DIFFERENCES AND WAY NOT MEETING
THE RIGHTS THAT THAT CHARGING
THAT FAMILIES.
SO EVEN WITH YELL AESTHETIC A
LOS.
WITH THERATES UP THEY WOULD
NORMALLY CHARGE TO SERVE THE
FAMILIES THAT WE FIND
SO WE ARE SEEING THAT IT'S NOT
WHEN NOT BAD COMPETITORS
COMPETITIVE WAS IT AS WE PEOPLE.
DO YOU KNOW ABOUT WHAT
PERCENTAGE REDUCE.
I DON'T BUT I CAN GET THE
INFORMATION TO MY HOUSE I WOULD
BE INTERESTING BECAUSE I MEAN
CERTAINLY AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
WORKFORCE ISSUES WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT COMPENSATION ONE WERE
LOOKING AT CAPACITY ISSUES.
ACTUALLY FOR ZERO
THREE
I THINK THE REALLY INTERESTING
YOU KNOW WHAT THE OTHER GOING
RATES ARE AND ONE PERCENT
IT IS EVEN.
WE HAVE SUBMIT INFORMATION I CAN
GET THAT I'LL BE HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT WITH THE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR MACROSS.
HERE ALL.
REALLY INTEREST.
BUT YEAH HER VERY INTERESTING
CONFLUENCE OF PRESENTATIONS
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH BUT I I
REALLY HAVE TO ADD. AND SOMEWHAT
UNUSUAL COMPLEMENT CRAMP WHICH
IS THAT IN LA WERE VERY INSPIRED
BY THE WORK YOU'RE DOING IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND. IN PARTICULAR INSPIRED BY
THE IDEA OF REALLY TENDER ENDING
A COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS WE'VE BEEN DOING SOME.
COUNTING OF STAY IN AND FEDERAL
SUBSIDY FUNDS THAT COME IN THAT
FLOW INTO ARE COUNTING ON A
REGULAR BASIS. BUT WE'RE NOT
INCLUDING EVERYTHING AND WE
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE THE. THE
HISTORY OF THE LOCAL INVESTMENT
THAT YOU DO BUT.
HOPE WE GET A LOT OF INVESTMENTS
OUT THERE AND COORDINATING THEM
IS NOT A BAD THING TO DO
ALRIGHT.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY ALREADY IN
DISCUSSION WITH THE SAME TEAM
THAT YOU YOU WRITE YOUR FINAL
ANALYSIS.
AND HITS SO IT'S JUST A REALLY
WONDERFUL SHOT IN THE ARM FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THEY DIDN'T
SAN FRANCISCO EVEN THOUGH WE GOT
MORE THAN ONE CITY IN ONE.
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SO FORTH AND
SO ON BUT IT IT'S REALLY INSPIRE
AND AND VERY VERY HELPFUL TO
HEAR YOUR. UPDATED REPORT ABOUT
WHAT THE SORT OF NEXT CHALLENGES
ARE GREAT THANK YOU.
THE COMMISSIONER COMPASS YOU'RE
BETTER.
I THINK YOU THINK YOU HAVE THE
FOR YOUR GREAT PRESENTATION JUST
OUT OF CURIOSITY WHEN BOTH AYE
WHEN BOTH THAT.
.
THE SET ASIDE THE INITIATIVES
ARE PUT IN THE AND THE BALANCE.
AND I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT
YOU'RE TWENTY SIXTEEN WOULD WELL
ACTUALLY THERE YEAH THEY WILL DO
A BOTH REALLY.
WE.
THE BILL WOULD REBOOTED NOTS UP
WHITE FAMILY THEY WORK THEIR WAY
OUT DAY WHEN WE AUTHORIZED
RECENTLY AND AND TWENTY SIXTEEN.
BOTH OF THOSE SET ASIDES I
MENTION UNDER ONE CHILDREN YOU
FUND.
CAN YOU TELL ME A LITTLE BIT OF
I'M WHAT YOUR COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY WAS FOR YOUR GENERAL
AUDIENCE FOR THEM TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU JUST YOUR AVERAGE FAMILY TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION
COMMERCIALS ANYWHERE OR. WHAT
DID YOU HEAR THAT RELEASED IT
WAS A VERY GRASSROOTS EFFORT AYE
BILLY I WOULD SAY THAT THE
STATE'S?
SOME JUST BECAUSE A VERY.
YOU KNOW POLITICAL CITY AND I
AND IT WAS GRASSROOTS IT WAS
BEEN AT THE BART STATIONS IT WAS
BEYOND THE MANY STATIONS IT WAS
PARENT VOICES IT WAS. IT WAS OUT
OF THE THE EDUCATED THE FAMILY
CHILDCARE ASSOCIATION. PEOPLE
REALLY RALLIED AROUND AND GOT
THE MESSAGE OUT THERE AND I HAVE
TO SAY EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW WE
MAY HAVE A SMALL A CHILD
POPULATION IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ATTEND WE TEND TO BE A PRETTY
LIBERAL VOTING CITY WHERE I DOT
SUPPORT CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
INITIATIVES AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE A VERY.
AND.
POPULATION MAY WHO ARE OPEN TO
THAT EVEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE
CHILDREN THEMSELVES.
I SEE THE VALUE IN THAT BUT YEAH
I MEAN.
I'D YOU KNOW WITH AS A AS A CITY
AGENCY WAY NOT ABLE TO DO THAT
ADVOCACY OURSELVES SO I THINK IT
IT FELL ON. YOU KNOW OUR IN OUR
IS ARCHED CENTERS ARE ARE.
ALL PARENTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS
TO GO OUT WE GET THE WORD OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION. PRE SHAVE YOUR
CONTRIBUTION.
OKAY WITH THAT WE WILL GO NOW
TO.
THIRD PART OF OUR AGENDA THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
PORTS.
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT WEJUST
WANTED TO TO RUN THROUGH.
Q. SLIDES ON ON OVER ALL.
I KIND OF WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE
WERE.
LOTS TO DO IN THE FIRST PLACE
AS A SPEAKER ALLUDED TO SO.
THERE ON THE SPOT ON THE YEAH
POWER POINT OF COURSE BUT THIS
THAT COMMISSION.
S. VISION WAS ASPIRATIONAL
LOOKING AT TEN.
BASICALLY THAT LONG TERM
SYSTEMS PROGRAMS AND FINANCING.
STEPS IN THE IMMEDIATE AND
SHORT TERM.
FUNDING ISSUES FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL.
AND THAT THE ROLE OF
PHILANTHROPY IN BUSINESS.
OF COURSE WHAT WE WANTED LOOK
AT.
WHAT THE SYSTEM SHOULD LOOK
LIKE FOR?
PROVIDERS TEACHERS FAMILIES.
.
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION NAY ON
ON EQUITY IN DISPARITIES.
AGAIN FINANCING WHAT THE STATE
TO PROVIDE AS WELL AS WHAT'S
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE.
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS MEETING
OUR NEEDS.
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITIES
COMPENSATION CERTAIN ISSUES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
AND THEN WE ALSO WHEN WE BEGAN
THIS PROCESS.
AFTER A CAPPELLA MEETING OR TWO
REALLY WANTED TO FOCUS ON HOW TO
GET DIG A LITTLE DEEPER AND SOME
OF HIS ISSUES SO WE. INTRODUCE
THE IDEA OF HAVING SUB
COMMITTEES.
A DIGGING A MORE SPECIFICALLY.
INDIA TOPICS THAT FINANCING AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
ACCESS WORK FORCE
AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES.
AND AGAIN THAT SUBCOMMITTEE
TENTATIVE PLAN.
IS.
.
IT'S PAST SPRING IDYLLIC AN
OUTLINE.
ON ON THE ISSUES.
THEY THERE IS FOR DISCUSSION
AND.
HOPEFULLY COMING CLOSE TO WHERE
THE RIG WENT AHEAD WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A PROCESS
FROM NOW UNTIL OCTOBER. AT
DEVELOPING A DRAFT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
NOVEMBER DECEMBER.
COST ESTIMATES.
PHASES IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THEN IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
JANUARY AND MARCH.
A REPORTS
COMING OUT WILL REVIEW THAT
HAVE A REVIEW WITH US
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND.
STATE AGENCY STAFF AS WELL AS
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND DEBORAH FINAL DRAFT AND I
WILL NOTE THIS WILL BE RIGHT
ABOUT THE TIME WILL HAVE A NEW
GOVERNOR.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
THINK IT'S A.
A VERY TIMELY APPROACH THAT
HOPEFULLY.
BACK INTO THAT THAT COULD
SERVICE WELL AS WE LOOK TO.
TO EXPAND ECM TWENTY NINETEEN
AND BEYOND.
OKAY SO WITH THAT WE WILL.
HERE FROM OUR FOR SUB. RIGHT
NOW.
AND WE'LL START WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
FINANCING.
AND ECONOMIC IMPACT OF BC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR A CHAIR.
I I'LL BE REPORTING ON THIS
TODAY.
I AM ONE OF THE MEMBERS BUT WE
HAVE OUR TWO CO CHAIRS NINA
BOOTY. ANSONIA AND COMPLETELY
BETTER WHO ME SHIP JUMPING IN.
AND OUT BUT SO TIMELY BECAUSE
AS.
EVIDENCED BY THE PRESENTATION
EARLIER TODAY. OUT WE HAVE DONE
A LOT OF RESEARCH ON THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
REPORT. ON NOT JUST TODAY BUT
I'M OBVIOUSLY AND FELLOWSHIP I
WORKED ON THE COMMITTEE AND THE
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND SOME OF
US HAVE TAKEN THE PIECES APART
IN HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING IT. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT.
THE OTHER IS THE.
LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE REPORT
AS WELL AS THE LABOR.
REPORT FROM UC BERKELEY.
CAN I GO TO THE NEXT ONE OKAY
THEN I CREATING.
A FINANCING STRUCTURE THAT
ULTIMATELY INCORPORATES THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF ALL OF THE
OTHER COMMITTEES. BECAUSE WE
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT ARE WE
GONNA NEED IN TERMS OF THE WORK
FORCE I WOULD WE GONNA NEED IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING ACCESS. I'M
IN AGAIN WHETHER IT'S TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM OR UNIVERSALISM AND
THEN WHAT ARE WE GOING TO NEED A
IN TERMS OF FUNDING. THE
ENGAGING FAMILIES TO SUPPORT
THEIR CHILDREN IN THE CARE AND
EDUCATION OF THEIR INFANTS
TODDLERS AND PRESCHOOLERS.
SO IDENTIFYING ON DEDICATED
FUNDING SOURCES FOR OF WELL
FUNDED SYSTEM AND YOU'VE HEARD A
LOT OF THAT IN THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTATIONS. THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE LOCAL.
STATE FEDERAL DOLLARS BUT AS
WELL AS POTENTIAL PRIVATE
FUNDING SOURCES.
ARE LOOKING AT THE PRIORITIES
FOR INITIAL INVESTMENT
I YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD WE'RE NOT
THINKING ABOUT THIS IN A ONE
YEAR. BUT THEY WILL TAKE THIS
TIME TO GET THERE SO WHAT IS IT
THAT WE NEED TO DO FIRST.
HOW DO WE NEED AND THE NEEDS OF
THE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN TO
ENSURE EQUITY? AND I'D YOU'VE
HEARD FROM I AM MANY OF THE
PRESENTERS AND IN THE MEMBERS UP
HERE. OF THE COMMISSION THAT A
BIG GAP IS IN THE INFANT TODDLER
AREA SO I WE'VE BEEN HAVING A
LOT OF THE DISCUSSIONS IS WHERE
DO WE START FIRST.
SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO. TO OUR COMPENSATE
OUR FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
ON BECAUSE THEY'RE THE LEAST
COMPENSATED AT THIS PARTICULAR
TIME SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
PRIORITY SEE THE PRIORITIZATION.
FOR THE FUNDING.
THEN I YOU ALREADY HEARD THE
PRESENTATION AND WE'RE EXPLORING
THE TARGET UNIVERSALISM AS A
POTENTIAL FRAMEWORK. TO LOOK AT
OUR FUTURE WORK.
I DEFINITELY LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNANCE AND SYSTEMS CHANGE
INCLUDING. UP THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES BECAUSE YOU HEARD EVEN FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE I SO WOULD WE
LOOK IN THAT.
WHAT ABOUT THE COORDINATION OF
ANY AND ALL OTHER SYSTEMS?
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
ARE PART OF THE DESIGN THAT
ULTIMATELY. OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS WOULD LOOK AT.
AND THEN.
WE ARE LOOKING AT INTEGRATING
APPARENTLY FOR PARENTS AS PART
OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
BECAUSE PART OF THE EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION.
COMES FIRST FROM THE PARENTS
THAT'S WHERE IT STARTS.
THOUGH I WILL. TURN IT OVER TO.
MARY.
OKAY.
I AM GOING TO BE GIVING YOU JUST
A REPORT FROM OUR.
EXPANDING ACCESS SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND SORT OF I KIND OF ALLUDED
TO IT EARLIER WITH OUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT TARGET
UNIVERSALISM BUT. WE ARE REALLY
YOU KNOW I THINK FOR A LONG TIME
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT ACCESS IT'S
REALLY BEEN ABOUT WHAT THE UNMET
NEED IS.
AND TRYING TO MEET THAT NEED.
BUT BEYOND.
I'VE JUST ACTUAL FUNDING FOR
MORE RESOURCES FROM WHICH
SERVICES WE DO WANT TO ALSO LOOK
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS FOR FAMILIES TODAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO RACE
IMMIGRATION LANGUAGE GEOGRAPHY.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW JUST GETTING
TO THE DOOR OF THE AGENCY THAT'S
GOING TO HELP YOU GET THE
ASSISTANCE THAT COULD BE A FULL
TIME JOB. AND A LOT OF LAND
MINES IN BETWEEN AND SO WE WANT
TO REALLY JUST TRY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THOSE ARE.
WE WANT TO LOOK AT JUST UNIQUE
POPULATIONS.
HOME YOU KNOW FAMILIES WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS DEEP
POVERTY CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
CHILDREN WHO ARE ENGAGED IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND AGAIN
JUST.
IN ORDER FOR US TO GET TO
UNIVERSAL AS I'M WE WE DO NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ALL
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO GET THERE.
AT THE SAME TIME MORE IN THE
SAME PASSED AND SO TO MAKE SURE
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS REFLECT
THAT.
ON ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE WILL
BE DOING THAT IS A SURVEY THAT
WERE SET OUT TO THE FIELD.
AND PARTICULARLY TO SORT OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND AND
ENTITIES WHO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THESE A UNIQUE SPECIAL
POPULATIONS TO HELP. US INFORM
WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS GO FORWARD.
WE'VE DISCUSSED THE POSSIBILITY
OF DOING A NEEDS ASSESSMENT AS
PART OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
SORT OF. YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERTS.
ON THE COMMISSION BUT. A WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT FAMILIES IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I NEED AND WHEN
THEY NEED CARE HOW THEY NEED
CARE.
WHAT THEY SEE IS QUALITY AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS?
AND WILL BE YOU KNOW DOING A
LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS OF OUR
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
MAKING SURE SYSTEMS ARE
SPEAKING TO ONE ANOTHER LOOKING
AT THE FACILITY NEEDS.
AND REALLY MAKING SURE THAT IN
ORDER TO BE TRUE TO OUR MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT WE ARE NOT
LEAVING ANYBODY OUT. AND THAT.
CENTERS FAMILY CHILD CARE AND
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR CARE
EACH PLAY A SIGNIFICANT PIECE.
TO OUR SYSTEM.
AND I THINK WITH THAT EARLY
BECAUSE SOONER TO.
THAT.
SO I'M REPORTING ON THE WORK
FORCE RETENTION AND DEVELOPMENT
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT COACH SIA ALAN
TWENTY MCMILLAN AND THEN ANOTHER
MEMBERS ON A COUPLE SVETA. IS
THERE IS SOME OF THE PIECES OF
RESEARCH THAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
OUT BUT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT.
MANY NATIONAL SURVEYS AS WELL
AS.
CALIFORNIA TO GET THAT STATE
CONTEXT.
SO WE HAVE WE'RE LOOKING AT A
RANGE OF TOPICS BUT OVERALL JUST
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A HIGH
QUALITY WORKFORCE THAT'S DIVERSE
THAT'S EFFECTIVE. THAT'S WELL
COMPENSATED AND PROFESSIONALLY
SUPPORTED.
AND ONE FOCUS IS OF COURSE BUT
COMPENSATION SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
COMPENSATION AND REALLY
COMPENSATING OUR WORKERS AS THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY ARE WHO
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN YOUNG
CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
COMPETENCIES SO COMPETENCY
BASED.
PROFESSIONAL PREPARATION FOR
THE WORK FORCE.
THIRD WE'RE LOOKING AT INC FOR
THEIR LOOKING AT TRAINING AND
PREPARATION SO INCREASING
PRACTITIONERS KNOWLEDGE IN THE
COMPETENCIES THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THROUGH
CREDENTIALING AND OTHER FORMS OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT IT SUSTAINABLE
THAT IT'S CONSISTENT AND
COHERENT.
AND THAT INCLUDES WORK
FAVORABLE WORKING CONDITIONS
LIKE PAID RELEASE TIME.
AND THEN THE LAST YOU HAVE TO DO
WITH.
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSIVENESS SO
FIRST.
DIVERSITY ACROSS SETTINGS SO.
INCLUDING FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR CARE GIVERS.
AND ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A
DIVERSE WORKFORCE THAT REALLY
REFLECTS THE CHILDREN THAT IT
SERVES.
AND ALTERNATE OVER TO THE
ENGAGING IN MEETING THE NEEDS OF
FAMILY.
THANK YOU DONE WE NEED FOLLOWING
THE FORMAT OF THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE PRESENTATIONS WERE
PROVIDED A FEW OF THE RESOURCES
THAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT. AND
ONE OF THE ONES THAT THAT.
MAY BE THE MOST UNUSUAL IS THE
IS THE BOOK ACTUALLY RESEARCH
BUT BUT IT'S.
VERY VERY WELL DONE ABOUT HERE
HOW PARENTS BENEFIT FROM THE
ADVICE OF OTHER PARENTS IN THEIR
SAME SITUATION. OF AND THAT
TOKYO PROGRAMS BRING PARENTS AND
PROXIMITY WITH EACH OTHER AND
THEY CAN SHARE INFORMATION NOT
JUST ABOUT TO OCCUR BUT ABOUT
ALL KINDS BUT THE THING SO.
THERE'S THERE'S
GLAD THAT AND THEN THERE'S MORE.
HOW THE INSTITUTIONS SUPPORT AND
ENGAGE FAMILIES BUT I THINK THE?
THE PIECE I WANNA TELL YOU ABOUT
BECAUSE I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT IT
I THINK ALL OF US ARE EXCITED
ABOUT IT IS THAT WE HAVE A PLAN
FOR DOING. FOCUS GROUPS WITH
PARENTS IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE SO THAT WE'RE GONNA
GET TO COLLECT QUALITATIVE DATA
FROM PARENTS IN A WHOLE VARIETY
OF PLACES USING A WHOLE GREAT
PROGRAMS. AND WITH A VARIETY OF
EXPERIENCES
SAID THAT THEY CAN TELL US HOW
THIS LOOKS TO THEM FROM THEIR
OWN EXPERIENCES BOTH WHAT HAVE
BEEN THE SUCCESSES AND THE PAINT
AND THE BENEFITS BUT ALSO THE.
CHALLENGES OF NEGOTIATING
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED SYSTEM.
AND SO WE'RE EXPECTING THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE RESULTS MAY
MEAN AT THE FINAL REPORT OF
RESULTS BUT SOME RESULTS FROM
OUR. AYE IN THE FALL.
WHICH IS WONDERFUL BECAUSE IT
CAN IS AS YOU'VE BEEN HEARING IT
WILL INFORM I THINK
RECOMMENDATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
REPORT.
TED TO ACTUALLY HEAR HOW PEOPLE
USE OUR EXISTING CHILD CARE
SYSTEM AND WHERE THEY SEE. OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES AND ALSO.
HELPING TO IDENTIFY WHERE THEY
GET THEIR INFORMATION.
BECAUSE IT IS A REALLY COMPLEX
SYSTEM OVER SYSTEMS ARE WAY TOO.
COMPLICATED PROBABLY FOR FOR
FAMILIES WHO ARE FACING MULTIPLE
CHALLENGES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN
BUT IT IS DIFFICULT TO NEGOTIATE
SOME WERE ALSO LOOKING AT.
WHAT IN THE RULES OF INFORMAL
COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS CAN PLAY
IN TERMS OF HELPING PARENTS GET
CONNECTED AND UNDERSTANDING
WHERE RESOURCES AND INFORMATION
THAT SO?
IT'S IT'S SO.
AS I SAY WE'RE ALL VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM MANY
PARENTS STAND AND NOT JUST FROM
A COUPLE IN THIS FORM OUT.
BUT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP FORUMS THAT ARE REALLY
DESIGNED TO.
GET GET THE BEST INFORMATION WE
CAN FROM THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
KNOW THIS SYSTEM RIGHT NOW.
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR ANY
OTHER. COMMITTEE REPORTS.
TING SAYING NONE.
WE'LL PROCEED NOW WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF ANYBODY IS HERE TO.
TALK TO US.
SHARE YOUR IDEAS.
GET AFTERNOON I'M TRACY
PATTERSON WITH CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING UP SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
BEEN DISCUSSED WHEN IT COMES TO
FINANCING CHILD CARE. AND THAT
IS FOOD.
FOOD IS CENTRAL TO CARING FOR
CHILDREN I CAN TELL YOU FIRST
HAND AS A FORMER HEAD START
TEACHER AND PARENT YOUNG
CHILDREN FOOD IS NOT OPTIONAL
WHEN IT COMES TO TAKING CARE OF
KIDS DURING THE DAY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT'S
SOMETHING THAT KEEPS BEING SEEN
AS A NICE TO HAVE EXTRA IN THE
STATE BUDGET AS OPPOSED TO
SOMETHING THAT IS COR TO THE
BUSINESS OF TAKING CARE OF KIDS.
DURING THE DAY WHILE THEIR
PARENTS ARE AT WORK AND SO I
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE TO THE
COMMITTEE JUST HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS THAT WE HAVE AN ADEQUATELY
FUNDED CHILD CARE FOOD PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE WE CUT STATE FUNDING
DURING DURING THE RECESSION WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN IT BACK AND
CHILD POVERTY RATES AT THIS
POINT ARE STILL HIGHER THAN THEY
WERE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
BEFORE THE RECESSION FAMILIES
HAVEN'T RECOVERED WHILE THE
STATE ECONOMY HOUSE.
AND SO IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT
WE RESTORE THE STATE'S
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO THE
CHILD CARE FOOD PROGRAM BECAUSE
A CHILD CARE PROVIDERS DON'T
HAVE THAT PROGRAM THEY JUST PULL
FROM OTHER PARTS OF THE FUNDING
THEY'RE PULLING FROM THEIR
PROVIDER RATES. BECAUSE FOOD IS
AN OPTIONAL WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
THE PROGRAM THEY MAKE IT WORK
REGARDLESS
SIR REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
BEING THOUGHT OF AS PART OF THE
FULL PICTURE. BOTH THE BUSINESS
MODEL OF CHILD CARE AND WHAT
CHILDREN NEED DURING THE DAY.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARY JANE
MCGUIRE FONG AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING.
PEACH WHICH ANOTHER ADVOCACY
GROUP.
LOOKING AT INTEGRATING THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMUNITY IN
SUPPORT OF QUALITY PROGRAM EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS.
I WHAT I WANT TO SPEAK.
SOMEWHAT BROADLY TO WHAT WE
HEARD TODAY WHAT AN INCREDIBLE
HEARING.
HOPE IT IS LISTEN TO WIDELY
ACROSS THE STRAITS THE STATE ON
THE STREAMING SERVICE.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY SAYING THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING THE ASHAR PARA
BELIEF IN THE DISCUSSION BECAUSE
IF WE CAN INCLUDE.
A PARENTAL LEAVE AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
QUALITY.
WORKFORCE COMPENSATION DILEMMA
ETCETERA.
WE'RE GOING TO TACKLE SOME OF
THE FINANCING QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTION THAT I ALWAYS WORK
WITH IS.
WHEN WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
THE FULL RANGE OF SERVICES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BIRTH TO
FIVE HERE.
THE QUESTION THAT I ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT IS WHAT DO BABIES ASK
ABOUT US AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RESEARCH AND I UNDERSTAND ROSS
THOMPSON FROM UC DAVIS WAS WITH
YOU A COUPLE OF TIMES BEFORE. A
LOOKING AT THE AMAZING
COMPETENCE
A BABY'S
TO LEARN WE CAN'T THEY ASK OF US
THE SAME THING THAT THREE AND
FOUR AND FIVE YEAR OLDS ASK OF
US.
THEY ASK ONE THING ARE YOU THERE
FOR ME TO SUPPORT MY INCREDIBLE
AMAZING CAPACITY TO LEARN.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE CLOSE TO
FAMILIARS.
SO THAT'S HOW WE GET INTO THIS
COMPLEX QUESTION OF WHO ARE
THOSE FAMILIAR IS TO THE BABY
INTO THE FAMILY. SO WE HAVE TO
BE BE PRESENT TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ASK
ABOUT THE FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS WITHIN OUR SYSTEM AND
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE NEXT DOOR TO
THE FAMILY SO THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS.
THESE ARE COMPLEX QUESTIONS
IT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE THE
BIGGER PERSON ACTIVE THAT WOULD
THAT.
LYNN COROLLA BEGAN WITH.
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THE WORK
FOREST'S?
AND THE ISSUE OF OF A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE IS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE PREPARING THIS WORK
TO DO THIS WORK WE CAN GET
THERE.
IF WE KEEP ALL THESE QUESTIONS
IN THE MIX WHICH IS WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
PEACH AND OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION
GROUPS HAVE BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY IN CALIFORNIA.
A FIGURE OUT THE QUESTION OF
WORKFORCE PREPARATION FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IT'S REALLY
COMPLICATED THE ANSWERS ARE NOT
CLEAR YET.
YET ONE ISSUE IS CLEAR WE NEED
RIGOR.
WE NEED DRAPER WE CAN GIVE WE
CAN GIVE ON RAKER AND WHETHER A.
SOMEBODY IS A TEACHER OR A
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER
SERVING INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
THEY NEED TO BE PAID WELL BUT
THEY ALSO NEED TO BE PREPARED
WELL AND SO LOOKING AT WAYS TO
DO A SYSTEM THAT IS. GONNA BE
COMPLEX IN SAN FRANCISCO MY GOD
YOU'RE REALLY HIT LEADING THE
WAY ON. A TACKLING COMPLEX
QUESTION BUT I HONESTLY BELIEVE
WE CAN GET THERE.
IN THE NAME OF OF QUALITY CARE
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH AND JUST I DIDN'T SAID
EARLIER BUT YOU CAN TRY TO TRY
TO KEEP IT TO THE MANOR TO. IS
NOT A HUGE LINE SOMEWHAT SIMPLE
BE A LITTLE BIT CHEN.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE NAIL
IN A MUCH ERICA CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS SUBCOMMITTEE COUNTY.
AND ALSO A UNION MEMBER OF UT
WCC P. YOU ALL WHILE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WHAT'S NOT DISCUSSED
IN TODAY'S HEARING I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE THE TIME TO SING
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE NEED THE RIGHT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. SO WE CAN
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN WE CARE FOR IN THEIR
FAMILIES.
WHAT THE HELL IN THE RIGHT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER AS A FAMILY
CHILDCARE ADVOCATE TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE NEED? EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION RECOGNIZED
IMPORTANT WORK IT IS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WILL GIVE US A SEAT
AT THE TABLE SO WE CAN BETTER
ADVOCATE FOR OURSELVES AND FOR
OUR FAMILIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
HI HEGEMONIC WITH THE LEARNING
POLICY INSTITUTE AND FIRST AIDS
WHEN I THANK EACH OF YOU.
AND THE PRESENTERS TODAY FOR
TAKING UP IS IMPORTANT ISSUES
I'M AND I AS I'VE COMMISSIONER
AYALA SAID REALLY TRYING TO BE
INNOVATIVE.
I A BROUGHT IN SHARED COPIES OF
OUR REPORTS WITH YOU I AM
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY LEARNING
SYSTEM WHICH WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE FINANCE COMMISSIONS RT
COMMITTEES ARE YOU TAKING OUT
CONSTRAINED TO LOOK AT. I
MEMBERS WE JUST WANNA SAY THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK WITH YOU
MORE ABOUT WHAT WE RECOMMEND FOR
EXAMPLE. I PROVIDING PROGRAMS ON
A SLIDING FEE SCALE AYE
REFORMING REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FACILITIES SUPPORTS AND
CONTRACTS THAT WE HAVE AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF LICENSED
PROVIDERS HAVING DEDICATED
FUNDING FOR PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR ALL EDUCATORS. AND
MAKING THE SYSTEM MORE
ACCESSIBLE FOR EXAMPLE BUT I
THROUGH AN ONLINE PORTAL FOR.
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
WE ALSO WANT A FLAG FOR ALL OF
YOU THAT I AM AT THAT LEARNING
POLICY INSTITUTE WITH OTHERS
WERE WORKING ON SOME I'M LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE COSTS OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. SAID REALLY
LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF THAT WORK
WITH YOU HOPEFULLY SOON BEFORE I
CAN I ADD TO THE UNMET NEED FOR
INFANT CARE.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH YOU AND REALLY
HOPE IT'LL BE A VALUABLE
RESOURCE ESPECIALLY.
AS YOU PREPARE FOR YOUR FINAL
REPORT THINK YEP.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE PETER
BARTON FIRST FIVE LA.
AND AS I HOPE YOU HEAR IT EVERY
SINGLE LIVING COMMISSION
MEETING.
NOT ONLY ON BEHALF OF FIRST WHY
THE LABEL OFFERS FIVES. WERE
READY TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES AND
SUPPORT YOU IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE
WE BELIEVE FIRMLY IN THE SUCCESS
OF THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
THAT THIS COMMISSION'S WORK
SUCCEEDS.
WE APPLAUD THE COMMISSION'S
CONVERSATION AROUND FINANCING A
REALLY CRITICAL AND MUCH
OVERLOOKED COMPONENT OF HOW WE
EXPAND ACCESS TO EARLY LEARNING
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE URGE YOU IN THE FOR
SUBCOMMITTEE TO BE BOLD AND
AMBITIOUS FOR TOO LONG OUR
APPROACH HAS BEEN MERELY
TARGETED INCLUDING. FOR THE
LIMITED FUNDING IN FIRST FIVES
AND NOW IS THE TIME TO HAVE A
REALLY BOLD VISION FOR ONE OF AN
EQUITABLE SYSTEM WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
WE ALSO APPLAUD THE
CONVERSATION ON TARGET THE
UNIVERSAL DOES. UNIVERSALISM IT
IS AN APPROACH THAT AND FIRST
FINALLY WE ENDORSE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IF OTHER
COUNTRIES AND OTHER STATES CAN
DO THIS WE CAN DO IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AS YOU ROLL UP YOUR
WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON KEEP MILLER
WITH CHILDREN NOW IN JUST ONE
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION.
FOR THE BIG PICTURE OF VISION
OF FINANCING IN THE C. SYSTEM
THAT WILL MORE EQUITABLY MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN.
AND THE MORE NUANCED DETAILED
DISCUSSION ABOUT YOU KNOW COST
DETERMINING FACTORS LIKE GLOBAL
WAGES AND OF COURSE QUALITY
SUPPORTS.
IN WE HEARTILY.
EXPRESSED THE NEED TO GO BEYOND
THE STATUS QUO AND WE KNOW THAT
THE COSTS.
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED AND SO AM
PARTICULAR GIVEN OUR POPULATION
WE KNOW OBVIOUSLY
EXTRAORDINARILY DIVERSE AND.
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME SO WE
REALLY NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT
OUR OF QUALITY.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO PRODUCE
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE TOUT THAT
WE ADVOCATE FOR.
IN OUR WORK AND AND ALSO JUST
ECHOING SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
THAT CAME UP TODAY.
WE REALLY ENCOURAGE AYE
AGGRESSIVE THINKING ABOUT.
THE ROLE OF THE STATE IN
PROVIDING CHILDCARE AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES ON THE
QUESTION OF GOVERNMENT CAN'T BE
SEPARATE FROM THE QUESTION OF
FINANCING.
AND SO IT'S REALLY NOT JUST
LIKE WHAT IS IT GOING TO COST
BUT WHAT ARE WE PAYING FOR IN
HIS ACCOUNTABLE FOR MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S DELIVERED. AND.
WHEN IMPLEMENTED AND THEN JUST
ALSO WANT TO HEARTILY AGREE.
THAT THERE'S THIS.
ULTIMATELY I NEED FOR A
METHODICAL MEANING FULL
TRANSITION PLAN AND REALLY TO
GET US TO POINT EIGHT. POINT B.
OVER A PERIOD OF YEARS.
AND THEN WE NEED TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT VARIOUS SCENARIOS THAT
YOU KNOW FACTOR IN CHANGING
ECONOMY POTENTIAL OF NEW REVENUE
SOURCES AND OTHER FACTORS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTINE INTEGRALLY I AM
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR
ZERO TO THREE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS THE THIRD MEETING THAT.
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
ATTENDING AND I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON THE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS THAT YOU'RE MAKING I
WAS SO EXCITED TO HEAR THE
UPDATES FROM EACH OF THE WORK
GROUPS.
AND JUST SEE HOW WELL ALIGNED
THEY ARE WITH THEM ARE MISSION
AT ZERO TO THREE TO ENSURE THAT
ALL BABIES AND TODDLERS HAVE A.
STRONG START IN LIFE INCLUDING
QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE
BUT ALSO TIME FOR PARENTS.
TO BOND WITH THEIR BABIES ALSO
NOTED AS SAPPY PARENTAL LEAVE.
HOW THEME EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND STRONG PHYSICAL HEALTH AND
NUTRITION? ANOTHER PIECE AND
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO YOU
TO HOLD ON TO IS THAT EVERY BABY
HAS AN IMPORTANT STORY TO TITLE.
AND THAT.
.
SOMETHING THAT WE LEARNED FROM
OUR NATIONAL PARENT SURVEY IS
THAT. WHAT PARENTS UNDERSTAND
AND RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND
EARLY LEARNING THE OFTEN MISS
THE MARK IN THINKING THAT THOSE
CRITICAL TIME PERIODS OUT FOR
THE BRAIN AND THAT DEVELOPMENT?
OCCURS WHEN A CHILD GOES TO
KINDERGARTEN INSTEAD OF DURING
THOSE
FIRST THREE YEARS SO UM I JUST
APPLIED ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS SOME
ESPECIALLY IN. REALLY THINKING
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF BABIES AND
TODDLERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHECK
FOR OUR WITH COUNSEL FOR A
STRONG AMERICA REPRESENTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT RETIRED MILITARY.
AND BUSINESS LEADERS ACROSS THE
STATE THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
AMAZING WORK YOU'VE DONE THUS
FAR AND THANK YOU FOR IN ADVANCE
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DO YOU. KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE IN THE FORM OF THESE
LEADERS UNEXPECTED MESSENGERS
WHO HAVE YOUR BACK.
THEY BELIEVE IN INCREASING
ACCESS TO QUALITY HIGH CHILD.
HIGH QUALITY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION NOT BECAUSE IT'S A
PUBLIC SAFETY AND NATIONAL
SECURITY INCIDENTS READINESS
ISSUE. AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO DO AND IF YOU NEED
ANYTHING WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY.
COMMENTS FROM COMMISSIONERS.
SEEING NONE I I I DID WANT TO
NOTE THAT WHEN WE STARTED THIS A
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION OF
COURSE.
IT'S ABOUT THE THAT THAT THE
PLAN A LONG TERM PLAN THAT CAN
GET LOST THAT SOME OF US APPEAR
OTHER JOBS AS WELL. AND SO.
WE WANTED TO USE THESE
COMMISSION MEETINGS IN THE
INFORMATION GATHERED TO HELP.
.
BOB FRAMED THE ISSUES TODAY AND
TOMORROW AND A SENSE THEY WERE
GOING TO ADOPT THE BUDGET. THE
NEXT MONTH IN CALIFORNIA JUST
KNOW THAT OUR LAST HEARING WE
HAD RIVERSIDE THERE WERE SOME.
IDEAS THAT CAME UP AS FAR AS
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND.
AND THAT OPERATING AN
ELIGIBILITY SOBRE TAKEN SOME OF
THOSE SPECIFIC IDEAS AND LOOKING
TO IMPLEMENT THEM IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET SO WHILE WE HAVE OUR PLAN
THAT WE'RE LOOKING UNVEILED A
YEAR FROM NOW. THERE IS WORK
THAT THAT HAS COME ABOUT THIS
PROCESS THAT'S HELPING US TODAY
SO. THANK YOU ALL FOR FOR
PARTICIPATING AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS.
ARE ON THE BUDGET FOR THE NEXT
TIME WE SEE YOU HANDOUT BUT
OVERALL. THANKS AGAIN FOR
ANOTHER GREAT HEARING AND FOR
ALL OF YOU. ARE PARTICIPATING
INCLUDING THE AUDIENCE THANK YOU